Well, good morning everybody!
Oh my gosh, I feel so well rested today because I passed out after the mademadon.
I think I slept like at least 15 hours yesterday.
I remember like making my waiting room and then I was out.
I was just... I'm gone.
Oh my god, I was so tired.
I think I needed to like catch up sleep from Dokome and Avcon as well.
Because I don't think I slept as much as I would have liked after the conventions there.
And then like after madon stream, I just was like, I'm gone.
I'm out.
I was like, I'm going to take a nap and then I get some work done.
But also because I slept really early on, I didn't get any work done after the stream.
So...
My staff was like, Dokie, we really need you to finish this up.
And I'm like, I'm sorry.
I just... I'm sorry.
I just woke up.
I was like, I'm sorry.
I took a nap and then I ended up sleeping.
I know I was going to get it done yesterday.
I'm sorry.
I'll get it done today after Sandland.
I know it could be an endurance stream today because I'm playing Sandland until completion.
But like I swear.
I swear.
I swear I'll get started.
But Dokie, Bureau Clock.
Fucking Bureau Clock.
Welcome to the Mediapart.
Welcome, welcome.
Oh my gosh.
Yesterday was fucking wild.
What a... I still can't believe we... everybody lived.
Everybody lived and then Bureau Clock came in with a steel chair.
I even...
I even foretold it.
I was like, man, I swear to God.
If we... if Julia just dies because of Bureau Clock, I swear to fucking God.
Bureau Clock.
Oh.
Oh, anyway, if you guys didn't know, the PAL World VOD is back.
With the chat fixed.
I have no idea what the fuck happened with the PAL World stream.
Because like, it got... the chat for it was like, broken.
And for like, a couple of days.
And then they took down the stream.
I got no... zero notification, by the way.
I had zero notification about PAL World VOD.
And then... um... so I was confused.
I was like, what happened to PAL World?
And then... and then like, I messaged my YouTube guy about it.
But like, he didn't reply back in time.
And then the stream just came back with the chat fixed.
I was like, okay, I said a lot of stuff.
I was gonna say, what did I say?
And I was like, no, I said a lot of very sketchy things.
I'm just wondering, I'm just wondering if it had to do with like, the YouTube like, bots being like, oh, my God.
She said so much stuff.
And then, they're like, they're like, concerned because the chat was like.
Is this a hostage situation?
Because what the fuck is going on in chat, too?
And that was like, so much shit.
That's why they took down the chat.
Because like, we both... me and the dragoons, like both of us, it's not just a me thing.
This was a team effort.
Both of us said some very extreme things during that stream.
So like, I would not be surprised if like, the VOD got flagged by like the YouTube bot system.
And like, so they took down the chat because they're like, they have to analyze the chat to see like, what's going on.
Because they're like, maybe this isn't friendly for viewers.
And then they're like, alright, we gotta take down this bot and match it up with the stream and see like, what's going on.
I'm not spreading the blame.
I'm sharing the blame.
Sharing is caring.
That's what Care Bears taught me, okay guys?
Did you not learn from Care Bears?
We gotta share it.
Hey, chat was taken down.
It wasn't the bot.
That was taken down first.
It was chat that was taken down first.
They targeted the chat first.
So something happened in chat that made YouTube be like, we're gonna take the chat down.
They didn't take the bot down first.
And then later, they took the bot down.
Oh, you want me to...
Oh yeah, you watch Care Bears?
Name all the Care Bears.
There's Brave Bear.
Wait, no, he's not Brave...
No, he's not a bear.
He's a lion.
He's a brave... Braveheart?
No, he's a cousin.
Okay, okay, okay.
We wanna know...
Okay, there's Grumpy Bear.
There's Joy Bear.
There's Braveheart, who's a cousin of the Care Bears.
There's Cheer Bear.
There's Sunshine Bear.
There's Sleepy Bear.
There's...
See, I told you.
I know the Care Bears and their cousins.
I used to watch Care Bears when they did reruns.
Like, three, two, one, go.
Something, something.
Care Bear's there.
Okay, maybe I don't remember Care Bear as much as I thought.
Maybe...
I had a Care Bear Sona!
Because I really...
I actually drew a Care Bear Sona back then because they released this new Care Bear designs.
And I thought it was super cute.
So I made myself a Care Bear Sona.
Because I thought it was...
Who's Dumpy Bear?
Is there actually Dumpy Bear?
Please...
Oh my gosh.
I'm going to look up Dumpy Bear because of you guys.
There's Bumpy Bear.
Dumpy Bear.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, there was...
There's no actual Dumpy Bear.
Care Bears.
Care Bear...
Care Bear names.
Okay.
Alright.
There's...
Oh my god, guys!
What's your Care Bear nickname?
What the...
Who the fuck is going to be called Magical Bear?
That's so stupid.
Alright.
I know my Care Bears.
I don't know if you guys know your...
I bet you guys...
I bet some of you guys aren't even old...
Weren't even old enough to watch the Care Bear TV show.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Speaking of that...
Speaking of like people not being old enough...
I actually...
Oh, there's Friend Bear!
There's Friend Bear.
There's Tender Heart Bear.
There's Share...
Oh my god!
I love Wish Bear!
Okay, Wish Bear was really cute.
I really liked Wish Bear's colors.
Um...
There's Fun...
Why the fuck do we need Fun Shine Bear and Cheer Bear?
It's redundant!
Your job is like redundant!
Your job is like...
You share the same job!
There's...
What's the difference between True Heart Bear and fucking Tender Heart Bear?
You're both hearts!
The Secret Bear...
That's not sharing.
Secret Bear should not exist.
Secret Bear is like...
It's like...
That's not...
That does not...
Like, what does that help with the children?
Kids should not have secrets.
If a child has a secret, you have to know the secret because it could be a bad secret.
Like...
Dad teaching kids bad things.
Secret Bear is a bad secret.
It's a bad bear.
Anyway.
Let's see, what I was gonna say.
Sorry, I got distracted.
Okay, speaking of children.
Okay, I need to tell you guys a story.
See, Sandland Street...
Sandland viewers get exclusive convention stories.
Because you are willing to watch part six of a JRPG.
So I will treat you guys...
You guys get the exclusive con stories.
Alright, so during like, AvCon, during AvCon, I was doing my panel.
Um, Dokimi, people who are at Dokimi knows this story because I told this at Dokimi.
But like, during AvCon, I was like, huh.
I was like, okay, I was, I started dropping like, fuck and like, saying shit, fuck and all that stuff.
I started dropping swears and then I was like, oh shit, I shouldn't be saying swears.
Because there might be children here.
But then I was like, oh, it's Australia.
It's alright.
You kids, Australians teach your kids swears at an early age.
So it should be fine.
And then... but then, the thing is, we had the Q&A portion.
Um, we were at the Q&A portion of the panel.
And then the second person in the Q&A, wait, no, not second, the first person who asked me a question was a child.
So I was like, I, cause like, he started talking on the mic and I was like, wait, how old are you?
Wait, are you a child?
I was like, are you a child?
How old are you?
Please be older than 13.
And then the child was like, I'm 11.
I was like, oh no, I'm 11.
I was like, no!
How
old are you to watch my streams?
And he was like...
I was like, no, you know, I can put whatever age I want when I join Discord.
And I'm like, no, that's not, that's not a good thing.
Oh my god, that's a, there's a reason why Discord has tighter regulation regarding age of children signing up for Discord.
And I was like, no!
And then, and then, for his parents, his mom was right next to him.
And I was like, I'm sorry, child.
I swore a lot.
And the child, the child was like, yeah, you were dropping like F-bombs while I was just sitting here.
And I'm just like, what the fuck?
I got called out by a child.
Oh my god.
Anyway.
Um, I felt very embarrassed that day.
I was not ready.
You know, I said that as a joke.
Being like, hee hee hee.
I didn't swear.
Because I assumed that everybody in the audience were not children.
But there was children at the panel.
And I was not...
I was not, I was not ready to find out there were children at the panel.
I did not realize that parents were putting me on the iPads.
Like I was the Cocomelon of VTube.
That was the day I found out.
I was the Cocomelon of VTubers.
You live long enough to become the villain.
The plot twist.
The despair.
Oh my god.
Also, apparently, I'm also like really, really good with, for pets too.
I am the Cocomelon of VTubers.
Because I had people come up and was like, I put your vibe on the iPads.
You are my dog's Oshi.
Because every time, because like my dog is like super hyperactive.
But the moment I put your vibe on for my dog, she like calms down.
And I'm like, that's so funny and cool.
But now that cements the fact that I am the Cocomelon of VTubers.
Oh my god.
Um.
Real pain, dude.
Thank you, super chat.
I'm the dog whisperer.
Hi, today is my birthday.
And I was wondering if I could get a happy birthday for my favorite bird with the most infectious laughter.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And of course, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Payton.
Happy birthday!
But yes.
At least like, okay.
If I am being used as your pet's stream of choice, create a YouTube account for them and subscribe to my channel.
That's the least you can do, right?
Yeah, but create a YouTube account for your pet and subscribe.
Gotta hit a million subscribers guys.
Oh my god.
I still can't believe children watch me.
I can't.
Oh my god.
Dokie Bird for all ages.
Guys, I'm so...
I'm universally...
I'm universally age appropriate.
Despite the things I say.
Um, Peachy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, no offense.
I don't think I trust you with my children.
What do you mean?
I'm the Cocomelon!
Okay, Cocomelon is not good for your kids.
But, okay, that sounds right.
Because Cocomelon is... I talked about this before.
But Cocomelon is not good for your children.
And it actually stops brain development.
Um...
I'm not joking when I say that.
Cocomelon actually, like, hurts your child's, like, brain development.
Because it's not... it doesn't grow the child's brain.
Yeah, like, the CDC actually wrote out...
Yeah, because they're like, you have to stop showing your children Cocomelon.
Because your kids are not developing properly because of that.
Because of their channel.
Um...
Yeah, there's nothing educational.
It's literally brain rot for children.
It's...
But, that means I'm different.
I'm better.
I give you guys fun facts, guys.
I give you guys fun facts.
Chat, it's not...
I do not rot your brain.
Sometimes I give you guys really fun facts.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What do you mean you're not kid friendly?
So, you're the reason my dog also started to swear.
Thank you for this.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fun facts makes you smarter.
It does.
Did you guys know...
Okay, here's a fun fact.
So, you guys know that the Mercy...
The pink Mercy skin recently came back to Overwatch.
Overwatch.
Um, and like...
I don't know if you guys know this.
But there was an underground pink Mercy...
Um...
Uh...
What's it called?
Black Market.
There was an underground pink Mercy Black Market.
Before they like...
Brought back the pink Mercy skin.
So like...
The accounts who had pink Mercy...
Because like...
The charity thing was the only way to get it back then.
It was like a one time thing.
And like back then, people were selling accounts for like $400 to $500.
And that was like the minimum budget.
People were like, I only have a budget for $500.
Please, I really want a pink Mercy skin.
And like...
So there was like actually an underground black market for pink Mercy skin.
Just for that skin.
Um...
Why is it pink?
Because it was for breast cancer.
Um...
And then like...
I could...
I could have sold my account!
I don't know if you guys know this.
But selling accounts is against TOS.
So...
Yeah.
So people...
So when the pink Mercy skin came back like last week.
The fucking thing quit.
And then like...
Like the market crashed so hard.
Because obviously now you can...
Now you can fucking...
You know, now you can buy it for like $10 or something.
I don't know.
I actually don't know how much it is.
Because my main account is in HKD.
Hong Kong dollars.
So like...
I don't know.
I'm too lazy to put the conversion rate.
I didn't log into another account.
I didn't log into another account to see what the prices was.
Um...
So...
Also, Blake, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome.
Um...
But yeah.
It's actually crazy that...
Just for the pink Mercy skin itself.
It was $400 to $500 minimum.
I didn't know this because like...
Uh...
Because I saw it like...
I saw it on Twitter.
And somebody screen capped some poor Mercy one trick.
Who's like...
Please, I only have a budget of $500.
I don't know.
I really want a pink Mercy skin.
I can only go as high as $500.
Because that is the budget I have.
Like someone was willingly asking for this.
For five...
I was like...
What the fuck?
Are you...
Oh Jesus!
Jacked up!
I couldn't believe it.
I couldn't...
I couldn't believe that like...
People were willingly paying that much for a fucking Mercy skin.
I was like...
I don't even know how much money you're making.
Of all things.
Like...
It's not even the best skin.
Like I'm sorry.
Mercy has like better skins than...
I'm sorry.
But I don't think the pink Mercy skin even looked that good.
Like...
I owned it from what the first...
From the very first charity.
Like the event that they did for like the OG charity event.
And I'm just like it doesn't even look that good.
It's just the fact...
It's cute...
Okay...
Hey, you can say it's cute though.
But like if you look at the Mercy tier skin list, like the pink Mercy is not the best skin they have for Mercy.
Like, I'm sorry.
Like, all it has is that it's pink.
I understand.
I understand people are like, I need everything to be pink.
But like, it's not even the best Mercy skin.
Of course there's a Mercy skin tier list.
You don't understand.
The Mercy main community is...
I'm sorry for all the Mercy pla- Oh my gosh, I'm so scared.
I don't want the Mercy community to like fucking flame me.
But like, you know what?
I already have like so many antis.
Like, I'll just get in the Mercy antis in here too.
Like...
Like, I'll just add Mercy players as antis as well.
It's alright.
It's already too late.
Like...
Um...
But...
I'm just...
The Mercy community is so scary.
As someone that...
As someone that used to be in the...
In like the Overwatch community.
If you piss off the Mercy main community...
Like, it is like...
Okay, so you know like...
The extreme side of...
Like...
The really, really bad side of like...
Of stans.
Like, doesn't matter what type of stans.
But like...
But like, before stanning things was a thing...
They used...
They used to be like...
All within the Mercy main community.
Like, it was basically like...
Before stans were a thing...
The Mercy community was sort of like...
The OG type shit.
Of...
Of like...
The extremely dedicated...
To Mercy.
Like...
If you have one...
If you have a negative opinion on Mercy as a character...
Like, you would get flamed so hard on Twitter.
Like...
Oh my god.
I remember cause like...
There was a whole movement...
Where like...
Mercy...
Mercy mains were asking for like...
Mercy to be buffed.
And then they're like...
What was it?
Mercy rework or something?
It was like some hashtag.
It was some fucking hashtag.
Where it was like...
Mercy reworked or something.
I don't remember.
It was so long ago.
And then...
And then like...
The other...
All the other players...
Were like...
I don't know guys.
Like, I think Mercy is good where it is.
And then if you had that opinion...
Of being like...
I think Mercy is good where it is.
You would get flamed so hard...
On the Mercy main community.
Because there was like...
And then it got to the point...
Um...
Oh yeah.
They like...
DDoS the official forums.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I remember that.
It got so bad.
That like...
Because there was a huge movement regarding Mercy.
Um...
And then like...
Rework Mercy.
That they DDoS the official Blizzard forums.
Because all they did...
Was like...
Spamming the forums to...
Demand a rework on Mercy.
And then at one point...
I remember at one point...
They started fighting amongst themselves.
Because the leader of the community...
Got exposed to be the leader...
Of the fucking rework Mercy movement.
Got exposed to be like a hater or some shit.
Like she got like fucking revealed...
Within like some fucking twitlogger or google doc.
To be like a really bad person.
So then the Mercy players were infighting amongst themselves.
Um...
Because apparently the leader of the Mercy...
Movement...
Would like shit talk other Mercy streamers.
Um...
And then so they were like...
Oh my...
Yeah it was a civil war within the Mercy community.
Because the leader of the rework Mercy movement...
Was revealed to be shit talking...
And like against other Mercy streamers.
And like being like a horrible person in general.
That she ended up deleting her YouTube channel.
Because it was such a bad expose.
That she deleted her YouTube channel.
And like privated her Twitter account.
Because people were like...
What the fuck?
Like people were like...
And then...
And then they all like...
Infight...
And then there was no more leader.
And then the rework Mercy movement died.
Like...
Yeah the rework Mercy movement died because of it.
Because they cancelled their own leader.
Oh my god.
Um...
It was...
It was so bad.
But anyway...
Yeah like I said like...
I'm...
I'm afraid of the Mercy community sometimes too.
Because...
Um...
They get very very passionate...
About Mercy in general.
I mean people are willing to spend 500 dollars minimum...
On a pink Mercy skin.
And that shit is crazy.
I know.
Like...
Not no skin should be worth that much.
It was for charity too.
It was for charity.
That's the worst part.
I feel like...
Jesus Christ.
You're selling...
A fucking skin that was for breast cancer.
For 500 plus dollars.
Oh my god.
I wonder if like people can still like...
Why do I know so much about it?
Because it was...
I used to frequent Overwatch TMZ.
And because like...
There was always so much gossip regarding like the Overwatch community.
Um...
And...
And like...
Um...
That was a whole arc that was there.
It was...
There was a whole TMZ dedicated.
Like a gossip...
A gossip like Reddit regarding Overwatch community.
And it was so funny.
It was so...
It was so interesting to read about.
Because like I...
When I used to be...
Play Overwatch...
I would read about it.
And be like...
Alright.
Time to read my daily TMZ news regarding the Overwatch community.
And like...
That was like one of the arcs that they had.
Alright.
Let's see.
Rework Mercy.
Okay.
Let's see if I can...
Um...
Actually, I don't know if they still...
If like...
If that's like...
Because I know like most of the really...
The really popular like videos about reworking Mercy.
Got deleted.
Because...
Um...
Like I said...
It like...
The leader got exposed to be a terrible...
Oh, there you go.
The rework Mercy movement.
I don't know if this...
Oh, yeah.
If you literally look up the hashtag...
Rework Mercy.
Like you can see like videos about it.
It's like...
Join the rework Mercy movement today.
What about Rein?
Like...
I swear to God.
Every...
Like...
Like they complain about Mercy.
But like Rein players...
Rein one tricks...
Rein mains...
Had it the worst out of everybody.
Like...
At least Mercy actually gets buffs.
Rein...
Rein players has been fucked so hard for like five plus years now.
And they don't complain.
I don't know.
I don't even know how they are still alive.
Oh my God.
Rein players are stronger than any of us.
Rein mains are actually like...
They're different.
They don't complain.
They just...
They just exist and continue to throw and grief games as Rein.
They don't care if their character is absolutely dog.
They don't care.
They're just...
They keep hammering and throwing other people's games by playing Rein.
It doesn't matter to them.
They got problems but they keep going.
Rein mains are still different.
It hurts but we're used to it.
I avoid every Rein player I meet.
I'm sorry.
It doesn't matter how good you are.
You are as Rein.
You're playing Rein.
Like, what the fuck do you want me to do?
Yeah, you might make it work for like one game but one...
But it's like one game out of 10 and like those...
I don't want to be the luckier side of your good...
good gameplay of Rein.
I don't want to be the lucky side of it.
No, right?
He's into it.
Yeah.
But the big ham... guys, it's Reinhardt.
The only way that like... the only way you guys can succeed is if you make the other team also play Rein.
But then if one of you guys... if the other team isn't a Rein main and they start losing, they'll pick Maga and fuck you up.
Like, what do you want?
Nah, the rest of your team isn't into that.
You might be super into Rein.
But the rest of the team wants to win.
Like, stop saying the truth.
Anyway, we're finishing Sandland today despite the long tangent we had.
The 30 minute tangent we had.
Guys, we're gonna finish... I swear, we're gonna finish Sandland.
I need to reboot Sandland because it doesn't register my controller.
But like, despite the long tangent we had, the long yap session, now... now we finished Sandland.
See, guys?
If you come to Sandland streams, you get these...
exclusive stories that the other dragoons don't get.
These tangents only happens in Sandland.
You... you guys... you guys got... like, you guys got spoiled today.
We're gonna beat the game, I swear to God.
Guys, we're gonna beat the game.
Why can't I... why is my controller not registering?
I don't understand.
Oh, there we go.
Now it is.
Alright, here we go.
We're actually gonna beat the game.
For real, guys.
Uh, we're back in Sandland.
I don't know if you guys know this, but we're back in Sandland.
Alright, open the door.
Exclusive tangents, yes.
That's right, you guys get the exclusive...
Wait, where am I supposed to go?
Oh, is it here?
Tricky Jumper Ken?
Where... which one's the objective?
Give the flowers...
Oh, here!
Okay.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God I already went here.
Uh, brother, thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, this way?
Oh yeah, it's this way.
Alright.
See you guys.
I told you we're gonna progress.
I told you guys!
General Ace!
We have news for you!
You look even worse than the last time we saw you.
Yeah, what happened?
Have you been getting any sleep at all?
Sleep hasn't been part of my life.
I've been reading the Lexicon for the past few days.
What were you doing?
I was in Forest Land.
What are you doing in Sun Land?
I have another brutal meeting ahead, so I can't talk long.
It won't help with your sleep, but here's our situation so far.
You see, it seems they're quite confident in their strength.
Epi says they've already moved a huge force near the border.
Our garrison along the border won't stand a chance.
I'm sorry.
Though to be frank, that goes for the entire- Don't we have an army too?
Oh, looks like it's turned into my army.
Our entire thing was being an army.
This entire country was run on by an army.
We've prepared lodgings for you.
You can stay there for- I think it's also because I sort of destroyed half their army too.
Maybe that's the thing.
I'll be taking my leave now.
We'll talk again later.
Yeah, you're right.
I was gonna say, wait, no, I destroyed half of their army.
I remember that.
But I also destroyed their army too!
It's equivalent exchange.
If the royal army won't be able to stop the Forest Land army, I'll-
Wait, why not?
What's the proposal?
I thought that's what we were doing originally.
Okay, but the king is worthless.
What the fuck?
Why does the king not believe in us?
Will we ever defeat the bounty hunter?
Will we ever do my job?
And actually hunt some bounties?
Yeah, I will.
No.
Last final episode.
Will Doki do her job?
And hunt bounties?
I'm not going to be the bounty hunter.
Alright.
So, what's the plan?
Let's head to the royal palace.
Aria should be done with his meeting by now.
I wonder if they managed to change the king's mind.
I'll set him straight myself if he's still finding excuses.
Alright, kill him over here!
You're General Shiva!
It's an honor to meet you!
Yeah, that's me.
The tiny little guy here.
I don't go by.
Never mind.
Who's talking?
Is he coming out of my voice?
Yes, sir!
Where's actual General Shiva?
Your majesty, please give me permission to fully mobilize the army.
Do I have to?
Are you sure you really need to go that far?
Supreme Commander Zeyu was able to keep them at bay all this time with just the border patrol.
The situation has changed.
Now, I'm going to go back.
Yeah, but that's because he was working in line with him.
Hmm...
But still...
If the royal capital falls, don't you know your head will be the first to roll?
General Shiva!
What are you doing here?
That's right!
I'm backing up General Aria.
Yeah!
I'm here too.
Yeah, that's me!
Yeah, okay bro.
I exist.
What is the meaning of this General Aria?
Don't tell me!
Have you joined forces with the demons to steal control of the country?
This is why we abolish monarchy because we have people like him in power.
The only people trying to do that are the ones claiming to reactivate Garam.
Just because he's like the son of somebody.
The forest land army!
The
princess of forest land, Anne.
Princess of?
I now fight as a member of the resistance, aiming to strip...
I wonder how much...
Shh!
You're not supposed to talk about the inbreeding part.
Maybe look at our...
I should say that.
Maybe I might get like...
I should talk about the inbreeding part.
The current monarchy systems.
In other words, she's the enemy of our enemy.
And you know what they say about them.
They're telling me this enemy of our enemy.
And the traitor general Sheeva.
And the demons who overthrew my army's commander.
Are all on our side?
Yeah!
I just don't know anymore.
You're not supposed to think, King.
You're literally a puppet for the army.
Zeyu is gone.
You're not his puppet anymore.
You're our puppet.
Please.
Stand up for your country.
And become a king for people to be proud of.
I'm sorry.
I met in-game guys.
Abolish the monarchy in-game.
Everything I say is in-game.
It doesn't apply to real life.
Disclaimer.
Royal blood won't protect you either.
You could end up on the gallows.
It's okay.
It's a sadland vibe.
They don't watch sadland.
We're safe.
We're safe!
We're hiding behind the Sandland Vine.
What the fuck?
Does he not have a queen?
There's a reason why you can't find a queen in Sandland.
Do you think Forestland is gonna be any different?
Alright, General RA.
I've graciously decided to leave everything up to you.
I'll do all I can.
Reporting in!
The Forestland army has crossed the border and is deploying into the southern desert as we speak.
Oh my god, it's coming!
The Forestland!
The Forestlanders!
Godspeed.
Them and their five tanks.
Thanks!
This will be all out war.
Are you ready?
Yeah!
I mean I was already killing people already in game.
So like, it's not gonna be any different.
Let's do this.
Yay!
Oh my god, five thousand!
Okay.
Nope, there has to be a faster way to get there.
I am not traveling five thou- Oh my gosh.
Thank god for fast travel, guys.
Thank fucking god.
I've spotted the Forestland army.
You already spotted them?
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, so nice seeing you at the Dokimi panel.
I was so surprised when I saw you in the artist alley.
I took the picture for the artist.
Thank you, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
I usually... I visit the artist alley before or before or after.
There's so many.
Are these all... wait, are these all the army?
Oh, this has to be the army.
It's always fun to meet artists at the alley as well.
Because I love buying Dokimarch.
What's funny is that they always be like, can you also have anything else on the table?
And I was like, no, that's okay.
I just want myself.
They were like, you know, you can also request anything else here.
I was like, no, that's fine.
I just... I just really want me.
Like, that's really it.
Oh my god, how strong are they?
Oh shit.
Okay, these guys are super...
Okay, we're gonna...
We're gonna grab... nope.
Where's the... how do I grab?
Okay, Rad, I need you to...
What do you mean, chat help?
Okay, we're gonna have to get rid of the officer.
This is the officer.
Uh...
Oh my god, Nikki!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
You did it!
You created an account for your dog!
Thank you for the account for your dog!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
See, guys?
I'm your dog's Oshi.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Who gave this dog a credit card?
Yo!
But also, who the fuck gave this dog a credit card?
He did it!
Nikki!
He's popular with the dogs.
Guys...
Figure yourself an Oshi who has...
dogs as fans.
Also cats.
Do cats like me too?
Guys, I need to know.
Do cats like me as well?
Okay, let's grab...
the bike.
Our very under level bike.
I trust Nikki with my finances.
Alright.
Is this the right one?
No, we have to find the one that has no name tag.
This one.
This is the officer.
Alright, no wonder he hits so hard.
Whoa!
Thanks for taking it!
Oh, that's awkward!
That is so awkward!
Alright.
Don't worry, we'll tell your wife!
We'll tell your wife while I'm in bed with her that you died honorably!
Okay, let's get rid of him.
And then reload.
Alright, man down!
Man down!
Wait, what?
What huh?
Alright.
Nice.
Uh, that should be everybody.
Right?
Alright.
Still two more.
Oh shit, he died?
What happened?
Who's dying?
What do you mean?
I'm doing everywhere.
Everything.
I can.
Let's take out their army's brain.
Okay.
That's fine.
That's what I've been doing this entire time.
Alright.
This is so easy.
Okay.
It's fine.
They're almost dead.
Oh!
He's holding still for me.
Oh nice!
It's okay!
They're level 18?
Okay, I think my tank's also level 18 though to be fair.
Now they don't know what to do.
Their brain's dead.
Alright.
Nice.
Then we got Royload.
Oh my god.
What kind of army is this?
When is dad gonna get a YouTube channel so NikiDodago can finally watch the stream?
Thank you for the super chat, Dark.
Thank you.
No.
I'm sharing.
Dad and I are sharing a channel together.
We don't wanna split the subs.
We're gonna do this.
Yeah, imagine if I hadn't upgraded the tank.
Yeah, that would've been really awkward.
Thank god.
Thank god I upgraded the tank, guys.
That was my idea, chat, to upgrade the tank.
Ooh!
Okay.
I alerted the guards.
Which one's the tank?
The brain.
Nope.
Is this one?
It has to be this one.
Right?
Are you the brain?
Yeah, you are.
Oh!
I caught you!
I knew it.
I fucking see you.
You thought you could pretend to be just like the other tanks?
You forest landers.
I'm not that stupid.
I might be from Sandland, but I'm not that stupid.
Thank you for the five gifted chips.
Thank you.
Okay, that's good that we have the others.
Oh, Link, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Hi, Toki.
Glad to be part of the crowd at one of your karaoke appearances.
Funny that I ended up being all the way over in Germany of all places.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god!
Is that you?
You have the profile picture!
Wait, there's more?
How is there more?
Okay.
I can't believe there's so many tanks.
It's like a whole entire army.
Who would've thought?
Wait, can I just go here?
Would I fail my mission if I...
No, I didn't.
Okay, thank god.
That would've been awkward.
Did I mess up?
Joining forces...
Oh my god, did I left?
Oh, okay.
Okay, that's good.
That's fine.
I was like...
I was so worried.
I was like, oh my god, should I fuck up the...
more... Did I fuck up the mission because I left?
Because I fast traveled?
Oh, yeah!
Oh shit, that's a big tank!
Where's our big tank?
Oh...
There's so many wives to go to bed with.
To tell them that their husband died honorably.
...
Tell you what?
Oh my god, he fits in the tank!
He brought like 4 tanks.
I don't know if that's going to help.
...
He's leading Seiyuu's elite guard into battle!
That's the king?
To think he would make a personal appearance on the front lines.
You call that fit?
He's stuck.
...
But don't kill them!
Take the king alive!
Ha!
Oh my god.
All I'm saying is that like...
What the fuck?
It's like... Holy shit, you just got run over the other tank!
Okay, I'm as close as I can be.
I don't know...
Oh shit.
It like fucking lagged my tank at one point!
...
My tank started lagging when he started firing!
It's just too big!
...
Oh, I don't know.
This is a big tank!
Oh no!
Oh!
Guys, I don't know guys.
I don't know anymore.
I have to give it every shot!
Holy shit!
Bro, please!
I need help!
I need assistance!
Wait, what?
Did I do it?
She was like half HP!
And then she gave up?
... What a cow!
You running away after half HP?
Couldn't be me.
...
There's a phase two?
Just like Souls?
...
He did what he was stuck!
How did he get in?
...
The rest is up to you, General RA!
Okay, bye!
... Someone oil him up!
...
Get the plunger!
Get the king plunger!
Oh my god!
All three of them!
It's so threatening!
...
Get the plunger!
Oh!
...
Is he okay?
Or do you have a wife?
...
There's not even blood!
How is he badly wounded?
...
Oh my god!
I...
...
That was my puppet!
I'm gonna control an army!
Yeah, isn't there like a chain of command?
Doesn't he have a second in command?
I feel bad for his second in command and he's just like, this is it, this is my time to finally show the military what I'm made of.
I'm gonna prove myself to General Arya!
And then he's like, to this old man that's retired 50 years ago, you can be the new commander.
This is a strategic withdrawal!
Our priority is to minimize casualties!
True, I mean he is the legend.
And then some old guy shoves you outside.
He's like, what was it, Conan O'Brien and that other guy?
Everyone, stop here!
Are you sure, General?
We're highly visible here.
It's alright.
Jay Leno!
Yeah, he's like, Jay Leno, step aside!
I'm coming back!
That's right, our eyes are trained in Sandland.
Yeah, that's right, forest landers.
You didn't have the sun because you had your trees covering it all.
You got spoiled by your trees.
What happened?
Did you copy?
Or you hit?
They got the cannon's base in suspension.
Pinned out of action!
Weak forest lander eyes.
They... don't
worry.
We're overwhelming them with sheer force!
What, two?
That's two?
We have three!
Also, I would've... yeah, I was gonna say, why did he not give the soldiers sunglasses?
Holy shit!
When did my tank go so fast?
It's David versus Goliath.
That's enough, Rosetta!
Anne!
Is this your idea of justice?
As if an ally of demons has the right to speak of justice!
Yeah!
You've got it wrong!
They're not the monsters you think they are at all!
Just your half-demons!
I'm a half demon!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh!
Oh shit!
I said that as a joke!
Oh my gosh, she's pretty racist!
We can resolve this if you'll just talk to us!
Keep your naive ideals in your...
Whoa!
This is a battlefield!
Take this!
Darn this oversized tank!
Actual racism!
Oh my god!
Anne... I want it.
Is that it?
Am I just gonna run away?
Fighter!
What's Ari's condition?
When did he fucking die?
No way!
Yeah!
I was like, what?
Get a hold of yourself!
He's gonna get into a coma!
What do you mean he won't wake up?
He just had a chest wound!
How did that affect the brain?
Like...
How did that travel all the way to the mind?
This guy's snoring!
I don't want B-R-O-C-L-O-C!
I'm really tired!
Okay, where am I supposed to go?
Guys, B-R-O-C-L-O-C!
Hahaha!
Okay, I go back.
Just a chest wound.
Should we go back and help Ari?
No, let's just sleep.
It's alright.
He's still in a coma.
It doesn't matter.
He'll wake up eventually.
Stay.
Please, make yourselves at home.
It's alright.
He's in a coma.
He'll wake up, right?
Alright, I'm gonna eat my lunch while we're waiting for him to wake up from his coma.
I hope you're well rested.
We look forward to your next visit.
Yeah!
Alright.
I gotta head over.
Guys, he's gonna wake up, right?
Right?
He's gonna wake up, guys!
I didn't realize he went into a goddamn coma.
But he's gonna wake up.
Alright, let us in.
You know why I'm here.
Wait,
is he awake?
Wait, you're back up?
I thought you were in a coma!
Wow.
Ew.
We're freaking shot.
He was just eepy!
Oh, a little tea and tea, like that, can stop me.
Fighting on through sheer willpower will come back to bite you later.
Look, it's nothing that I can't handle, alright?
Ah, to be young.
All joking aside, though.
What's the prawn business?
What the fuck?
It's been a day!
How did they build three bases?
That's so fast!
That makes sense.
Yeah.
But like they built three in a day?
It's not fair to have trees.
They brought their goddamn trees to build those bases.
What do you mean on a losing streak?
We fucking killed so many people.
Okay, what do we need?
New parts can be made at the base.
We need to join forces.
We need to...
Okay, these are all the bases.
I'm gonna see if I can upgrade.
I'm gonna check if we can upgrade anything.
Kick out the force land squatters!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
No name!
Alright.
We're gonna... We're gonna see if we can upgrade our tank.
Mmm.
Do you need any?
Mm-hmm.
Let's see.
Dragoons.
What do we need for premium steel and premium bulk?
I'm pretty sure I can make those, right?
Just go all in on the tank at this point.
Hahaha!
I feel like... I feel like we can just go all in on getting better tanks.
Alright, let's see.
Attack, um...
Okay, we don't have new parts, but I think we can upgrade our parts, right?
Premium steel, premium meter, premium gunpowder.
Alright.
See you later!
We gotta go to the parts lady.
Parts lady!
Oh my god!
Master drop!
Thank you for the 50 gifted ships!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
Really appreciate it!
Alright, where's the premium shit?
Do you not have premium stuff?
Bro, what the fuck?
Give me back my...
Thank you!
Bro!
Bob was better.
The forest landers had premium stuff!
Hey!
Is it... oh!
Oh, nice.
I got... ooh!
Oh, wait!
Isn't this really good?
Wait, wait, wait!
Which one was good?
Remember you guys told me to... um... get some of their gun stuff?
Purple guns?
Yeah, but which one?
Can we get the EMP gun and laser?
Okay, we're gonna grab that.
And then we're gonna grab that.
Alright.
Bring me any rare items you find.
Alright, let's see.
Let's see how good the parts are though.
I heard like... you guys were saying that the guns and lasers were really good from the cat guy.
From Najin Boo.
Parts...
Uh, customized vehicle...
Uh...
Oh, you got EMP gun?
Wait, but then the damage isn't as good though.
The damage is so low!
Is it worth it?
Or nah?
Um... lower damage, but...
Uh...
Is it worth it though?
Guys?
Or should I keep...
Maybe upgrade?
Damage isn't everything...
DAMAGE IS EVERYTHING!
I don't know what you're talking about.
Okay, we'll try it.
What world do you live in?
Where you think damage isn't everything?
Also, what else did I buy?
I don't remember what else...
What else did I buy?
Other than this...
I don't remember...
For what...
Where did the laser go?
Wait, which tank uses the laser?
Because clearly it's not any of this...
Big number makes unga bunga brain happy.
Oh, it's in...
Which one is the...
Which one was the laser?
Oh, the laser was the mecha?
Was this?
No, it wasn't.
Which one was the laser?
Where the fuck?
Where did I buy the laser for?
The hover one?
Was it the hover?
What the fuck?
I don't remember which gun was for the laser.
It's check under options?
Okay, options.
Okay, wait, what options?
Wait, I'm confused.
It's an option part?
Oh, okay.
It's an option part.
What does that mean?
Oh, here.
Oh!
Virus of power was causing destructive.
You know what?
Fuck it, let's go.
Damage!
All in!
And then we upgrade part.
Apparently, okay, we need...
Where the fuck are we getting premium meter and premium steel?
We do not have either of those.
I guess we have to... I'm gonna go visit...
I guess I have to visit.
I guess I have to visit, like, the other side.
You're right.
Who needs armor when you have laser?
We need, like, premium steel.
We need to go to... here?
These guys might have it.
The junker market might have it.
Does he sell it?
Armor up.
No, he doesn't sell it.
Do you sell it?
Do you make the good shit?
You do!
Okay, that's good.
Okay, we're gonna grab all of the premium...
What is it?
Premium steel and premium bolt, right?
Okay, we need...
A lot of premium steel.
And then we need...
Premium bolt, right?
How many premium bolts do we need?
I don't remember.
Oh my god, this guy...
Why can't I have him in my town?
Why?
Why can't he live with us?
I'm gonna have four premium bolts just in case.
Yeah, like, we don't need...
We don't need...
What's her name?
Workshop lady?
This is better workshop lady.
Kidnapping.
Alright, let's see.
I actually don't remember what we needed, so I'm gonna double check.
Two plus two is five, right?
I don't know!
I don't remember!
Alright.
Because I want to upgrade my laser.
Alright, parts.
Upgrade part.
Okay, we need premium meter.
Okay.
We have Justin...
Premium meter?
Oh shit, okay.
Alright, we got...
Well, I hope that they're not gonna be using my premium steel to make the premium meter.
Because that would be very...
Uh...
Very awkward.
Get the A-N drive?
What the fuck is your...
What the fuck is it?
A-N drive?
Uh...
Oh, nope.
We gotta go here.
And then...
Talk to premium meter.
Oh god, I hope...
Wait, how many...
I forgot!
How many do I need to get for the premium meter?
Premium meter.
Guys, it goes in one ear and out the other.
Guys, it doesn't matter.
They don't have premium meter.
What the fuck is a premium meter?
How do you not have premium meter?
I don't know what it is, but how do you not have premium meter?
Where do I get premium meter?
The forest land workshop would have premium meter.
They drop from enemies?
What kind of enemies?
Maybe...
What kind of enemies drop meters?
What the fuck?
What do you mean?
Is it meter?
It's a meter but premium.
Bob would have had a premium.
Do you have a premium meter?
What kind of enemies drop premium meter?
One meter equal.
A unit of measurement.
Okay, this is not...
Okay, this is not the right gun.
Boom!
Oh, that is overkill.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, I got premium gear!
Alright, are these all the bad guys here?
Wait, that was it?
No, I just went the wrong way.
Nevermind.
They weren't even part of the enemies.
Okay, sorry.
I went the wrong way.
Thank you, Zeon, for the backseating.
I really appreciate it.
Queenie, what is it?
I thought you were Canadian.
Okay.
Oh my god, it's splashing.
Apparently, there is the forest land officer here somewhere.
Is it this guy?
Oh, it is this guy.
It's okay.
Laser is coming in.
Oh my god, he can block too?
That should be illegal!
Oh god.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, he can block all of this.
Oh!
Wait, that damage is insane.
Insane!
Wait a minute!
That's some insane damage right there!
Holy shit, alright.
And then we...
We get like...
Wait, that is insane.
Alright.
Do I get premium meter?
Premium gear?
Premiums...
Premium meter!
We did it!
We got premium meter!
Prize drop by, have Bramley assigned so that to get the best part, be as many enemies as you can.
Legendary, rare or even higher capacity.
Ooh!
Wait, that's like legendary part.
Alright.
You guys don't matter apparently.
So I can just shoot you guys away and steal your part here.
Alright, nice.
We finally got... We got another premium meter!
Nice!
Alright.
That... counter offensive?
Enough?
Eat everybody?
You know what?
I'm gonna defeat these guys for the premium meters.
We actually need upgrades.
Like...
It might be... It actually might be a good idea to...
To kill these guys for like some upgrades now.
Alright.
Is that everybody?
Did I do it?
This is counter offensive.
What does that mean?
I'm gonna kill everybody.
Finally.
I finally learned what a meter was!
Is that it?
Use LBRT.
LBRT?
Oh!
I see it.
I think I'm pretty sure I killed everybody.
Right?
Hello.
No.
Because it keeps telling me to go back.
What?
Who's still alive?!
Who's still alive and do you have a way for me to tell that you were a hero?
You should check the map...
Oh, there they are.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
I did not realize...
Okay.
You know what?
I'm gonna...
Oh, wait.
Oh, he's already dead.
Don't even believe this.
Look, all I'm saying is that I will make sure that your family knows you were a hero.
Premium meter?
Ooh, scorpion oil.
Why are you doing all that scorpion oil over there?
Can I rob you guys?
Is there stuff to steal?
Nope.
Okay.
Alright, it's time to go back to Spino!
The wife hunter.
There's a bounty on your what?
Oh wow, I can't believe there's a bounty on you, sir.
Alright, let's see.
Upgrade part.
Oh my god, finally.
Okay, premium gunpowder.
Okay, I think I can also...
Customize vehicle.
Can upgrade dragoons, right?
Vehicle.
Upgrade vehicle.
I need premium steel.
I need one more premium steel.
Oh, I don't have premium ore.
I don't know where to find premium ore.
There's so many premium!
Oh, I'm saying... What do you mean it's bad?
I'll have you know I'm the Coco Melon of the world.
Okay, let's see.
Ugh.
I have no checkpoint around here.
Holy sh**.
I actually don't...
I never went to the Hidden...
It's hidden!
How was I supposed to know where the Hidden Cliff Village was?
I was supposed to know where the Hidden Cliff Village was.
Not the...
Here we go!
Cocomelonavity, please.
Yoki, you're not supposed to say that as a positive thing!
Okay.
What's this?
Get the flowers?
No.
I don't care about this child's flowers.
I gotta figure out how to get here.
You could look for it.
But like, I don't know what type of ores that is.
There's so many ores around me!
They could be bad ores!
Oh, is this where the flowers are?
Yoki Melon, the brain rot is real!
Gab, they give us...
It's a demon!
Yeah!
She's blind for a blind girl!
For a child!
Oh, Naki.
Okay, but why is he bringing flowers to a blind child?
That's not a twist.
But why do that for a human?
Yeah.
She complimented my singing.
What the fuck?
How old are...
First off, Naka, how old are you?
I was walking along, humming to myself, when suddenly, I heard clapping.
When I looked around, there she was.
She said I was good.
Are you that good a singer?
I like to sing, but no, I'm not very good.
But she still thanked me.
She said interesting scents and sounds make her happy.
So you've been bringing her flowers?
I wanted her to enjoy their scent.
That's pretty sweet.
Why not just sing for her if she's sure you're good?
Yeah.
I can't.
She won't be happy anymore.
She's literally blind!
She doesn't know the concept of demons!
I'm not so sure about that.
She doesn't even know what they look like!
Cause she's blind!
She was looking for you so she could thank you.
What?
I don't need her to.
Once was enough.
Never mind that.
Prince, I have a request.
What?
What is it?
The thing is, I want some alpha raptor essence.
What the fuck do you want with al- You want me to be an alpha?
What for?
I need it to make a cure for her sight.
What?
But I'm not strong enough to defeat an alpha raptor.
You could cure her sight using that essence?
What?
Where did we get there?
First off, it was just bring flowers to a girl that would compliment you.
And now you're like, I'm gonna cure her blindness now.
Yeah.
Alright, we'll see to it.
Is that okay with you, Prince?
Guys, this is why you need to compliment people more.
Like, what the fuck?
This guy is deprived of compliments.
He's- He got one compliment and now he's gonna fix the blind.
You mean it?
Great.
If you- What if the next person you compliment cures cancer because of you?
There's an alpha raptor west of here.
You just have to beat it.
West.
Got it.
Thanks.
I'll get the other ingredients in the meantime.
What?
They already killed one already.
Wait, where did he go?
Pretty sure I ha- I've- I've killed so many dinos.
I haven't?
Wait, I actually haven't killed a raptor?
Oh my god.
I am like...
I think I'm losing my touch.
You mean I didn't kill a raptor?
But I killed so many!
Guys, I know you're trying to compliment me, guys, but I'm not gonna be the person that's gonna cure cancer.
I'm sorry.
Oh shit, I forgot.
This is the jump bot.
God damn it!
Alright, let's see.
God damn it, I forgot.
Sorry, that was the shoot button.
I was so used to shooting.
I don't remember any other buttons.
Wait, would that be the premium ore?
Maybe the premium ore is over there.
But you might!
Okay, guys, guys, I need you guys to stop coping here.
I'm a fucking VTuber, not a doctor.
Or a scientist.
What does that mean?
How do we get there?
How do we- How do we get there?
Did I go the wrong way?
How do we get there?
Oh, I guess I'm just gonna fuck it.
I'm gonna- I jumped all the way here for no reason!
I can't look at this map, man.
Why is this- Okay, let's see.
We gotta get out of here.
And then we go this way.
Alright, here we go.
This map is so difficult to look at.
Where are the ores?
I don't understand.
Ooh!
Okay, we gotta- Oh, oh, wrong way.
Oh, that was a cool Akira- Akira thing, but like, I need to get this.
Alright, nice.
Alright, off we go.
Alright, time to kill more- Forest land- Sorry.
I meant forest landers, guys.
Not sand landers.
Forest land- I fight for you guys!
I fight for the people!
Haha!
Or like, for whichever- Whoever on me pays me more!
I'm a mercenary.
It's all about the money!
I got the...
Paternal...
Rubber.
Woop!
Alright, time to swap!
Gotta make the most of the journey.
Here we go.
Where's the boss?
There you go.
Where's big boss?
That's right!
I got a laser now!
And it's full- Oh my god, wait!
Okay, I sort of wasted that charge.
Oops.
I need to like, time like, the charges and stuff.
Because I don't know how much charge is- How long I have to charge to get the full power.
Come on, I know you're here.
Why are you hiding behind the rock?
Nice.
Oh my god, he used his men!
To block my charge!
Okay.
Last one.
Phew!
Alright.
Now for the people.
I don't know what this bike is gonna do.
But okay.
Are you just gonna ram into me?
Okay, that's it.
No more Mr. Nice Guy.
Alright, that's one of them down.
Oh my gosh, you guys are very brave.
Don't worry.
You guys are very brave, I'll admit.
And I'm gonna steal your loot.
Oh, there's so much loot!
Is there any loot?
Is there more loot?
I love loot.
Is there more stuff?
Did you guys left this base?
You built this in one day?
Jesus Christ, how did they build this in one day?
There's loot over there!
Yeah, there's so much... so many purples.
Alright, yoink.
Wait, why is there like empty scrap here?
Who died there?
Who fucking died there?
Hey, you see that raptor?
Sorry.
You see that raptor?
You can help us out, worry about it.
Bye guys.
Bye.
tina.
What's happened?
Bye, I'm not gonna destroy you.
It's okay.
You understand?
Leave us alone.
No, I don't need to kill the scorpions because like...
Because like...
All we need is premium shit now.
We don't need stuff from the animals.
Oh my god, look!
Such a happy family!
But we can kill this guy.
Oh, it's the alpha raptor!
We need to kill him anyway!
For the essence!
For the essence, guys!
You don't understand!
Oh shit!
Okay.
Alright, no wonder he's the alpha.
Alright, there we go.
Thanks.
And then...
You're a child, right?
Yeah, that's a child.
I gotta make sure I shoot the right one.
Give me a sec.
There we go.
Alright!
Live on, childhood!
You're free now!
Childhood!
You're free!
You can do whatever you want!
You have the whole land to yourself!
I'm the alpha now!
Alright, let's see.
We gotta...
Is he still chasing me?
Look, he's having a great time!
Oh shit, okay.
That was a little overkill for these guys.
Oh!
Alright!
Okay, you called me a monster but Beezlebub was like...
Hey, that was fun, I guess.
What does that say about Beezlebub?
It's like...
That was fun.
Okay, I gotta get rid of these guys.
Okay.
Get over here.
Get this hover fucking crap out of here.
Get this hover crap out of here.
Oh shit!
Get... Whoa!
Okay, we need a repair.
Yeah, he's a demon that doesn't kill with exceptions.
He's like, but I don't kill.
But then clearly... Clearly he has exceptions!
It's a lie!
He does kill!
Okay.
I'm gonna get rid of...
I'm gonna get rid of him and I'm gonna get rid of him.
Woo!
Ow!
Alright, where's this guy?
There you go.
Nice.
He only kills when it's fun.
And I'm the monster here!
Oh, there's the boss.
There's the... There's the boss.
Okay.
I'm gonna charge this up.
Phew!
Wait, that didn't hit him?
I'm intrigued though.
There we go.
Whoa!
Okay, we gotta make sure he doesn't punch us.
There we go.
Ooh, look at that damage though.
You're both monsters.
There's no, like, distinct...
That's not true!
I'm only doing what the game's telling me to do.
At best, I'm a puppet.
Okay.
I'm just a puppet.
I'm not free will!
I'm just learning from my artificial intelligence!
Yeah.
Is that it?
Just following orders.
Exactly.
There's more?
Oh, we have the Sandline bases.
Yeah.
I almost forgot about that.
Because we... We... We killed the Sandline.
We killed the bases that are, uh...
The bases that are, like, uh... What is it called?
That they built themselves.
So now we have to kill the ones that, uh, took over in Sandline.
Alright.
Yeah.
Good soldiers follow orders.
And I'm a good soldier.
Do you need...
Uh, let's see.
Upgrade part...
Oh, yeah.
Customized vehicle.
I got so many parts.
Ooh!
Shots exposed on impact with a chance on enemy...
Should I just keep the EMP gun or do the purpose?
I don't know.
Fires in.
Oh my god.
That guy... That's too weak.
Do I just... Do I just, like, stay?
Keep the EMP?
Okay.
I'll keep the EMP then.
Oh my god.
But there's so many, like...
Uh...
Let's see.
Explosive lasers...
Oh, good luck charm.
Chip that works.
So I increase the chance of defeated dropping...
Ooh!
Okay.
I want good luck charm.
I'll take the good luck.
How much do I need to...
Okay.
Customized vehicle...
Uh...
Upgrade part...
I need premium steel still.
God damn it.
I don't have enough...
I don't have enough, like...
You can make a backup tank.
I don't need backup.
Uh... Upgrade vehicle.
There's still... Oh wait, I can upgrade this.
Nice.
Okay.
We'll upgrade that then.
Uh... Super hard Krakdor alloy.
What the fuck?
Do I have one of those?
I don't know.
Oh, I can get another chip slot!
Yes!
Finally.
Alright.
And then...
Parts...
Uh... Customized.
Finally, I can have another chip slot.
I'll just use the power chip...
Oh!
Machine gun.
Quick reload.
Incinerate chip.
Uh... When using cannons.
Ooh!
I like that.
I want them to be on fire.
Uh... Acceleration.
Increases vehicle.
Reduces cannon reload time.
Quick reload would be nice.
Like, but I feel like...
My laser...
Does that affect the charges, though?
I think that's fine.
I think the incinerate is better.
Uh... Would it actually be better?
I don't know.
I'm using the other...
I use the other gun until my reload's done.
Uh...
I mean, I could try...
Quick reload.
I'll try quick reload.
Okay.
See you later!
Yeah, I feel like the gun reloads pretty fast.
That's why I'm gonna do incinerate.
I'm gonna do incinerate.
Just cause I feel like...
I feel like I reload really fast already.
So, like, I don't think I need it.
I'd rather have the incinerate.
See you later!
Alright.
We go.
Go now.
I just need to find more premium ore wherever that is.
I need to find more ore in Forest Land.
That's where they have all the good shit.
Forest Land has all the good shit.
Alright.
Here we go.
I'm heading to the capital.
Why do you always ask me that?
Just let me in.
I'm literally outranking you.
Alright.
Time to eat more of my dinner.
Lunch.
Yeah!
That's me!
Munch, munch.
Wait, what?
Okay, nevermind.
Guess not.
I thought...
I thought this was gonna be a longer cutscene.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Alright, I'm ready.
Nevermind.
Off we go.
Okay.
Alright.
I thought it'd be a longer cutscene, but that's okay.
Here I go.
It's this way.
Where the fucking...
Where do they call it?
What are these guys called again?
The robo-gangsters I'm doing here?
Not caring about how there's a war right now with the Forest Landers?
Alright.
There's one of those bases.
No time to eat, soldier.
It's time for war!
Alright.
Is that it?
I can barely see because there's a giant checkpoint in front of me.
.
Alright.
Okay.
Woo!
Alright.
Get away from me.
Nice.
Alright, we gotta make sure we shoot...
Shoot the tank.
It's a tank.
Okay.
We gotta reload and then shoot the humans.
And then...
See?
We don't need the reload!
The reload is already so strong!
Oh my god.
Did I get him?
Okay, I did.
I couldn't tell.
It's so hard to tell sometimes.
This giant checkpoint is actually so...
What?
The giant fucking area.
I'll be like, this is where you have to go.
Alright.
Nice.
We got one checkpoint back.
Oh, you're still alive?
Your friends are dead!
Alright.
Now everybody's dead.
I think we took out all the enemies here.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
Alright, let's head to the next base.
I'm gonna rob your wallet too.
Next base is over here.
How do we get here?
I need to figure out how to get here.
How the fuck do I get there?
Does that need water?
That's in the water, right?
I feel like that's in the water.
It's like a bridge here.
What the fuck do I...
What?
I hope it's in the water.
Alright, let's see.
The worst part is that this car is so slow.
And I can't...
You can't go faster.
It's such a slow car.
Oh my god.
Bye bye.
Which campsite?
There's a campsite here?
Really?
It's open to all travelers?
It feels like it's being...
It's open to the rebels right now.
Or the Sandlanders.
No, it's Forest...
Sorry.
They're all blurring together.
I've been like on so many different sides.
I've been...
Fusible didn't kill anyone.
Did they...
Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, you're right.
You're so...
You're so true, man.
So true, Persona.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's not my fault my tank hit somebody.
What do you call that in the legal system?
You know, like hit it...
It's not like hit it runs or a thing and that...
Alright, how do I get up there?
You just start by observing them carefully.
Knowing what they can do...
And just get off this?
And what their weaknesses are will help you fight effectively.
Serve them, huh?
Not a good spot.
Try that next time.
What the fuck?
How do I get up there?
Yeah, it's not like manslaughter is a real fucking crime or anything.
Alright, do I get up from here?
Oh, it's from here.
Okay.
Nice.
We figured it out.
Your audience knife killed him, not me.
Wait, we figured it out, guys.
Are these the bad guys?
Oh, shit!
Hey there!
Hey, guys!
Guys, I found the bad guys!
I found the bad guys!
It's okay, I did it!
I found him!
They were...
Guys, who would've thought they were the bad guys?
Oh my god!
I cannot see!
I can't see!
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
That was like so many different things on my screen.
Alright, nice.
Give me your shit.
Give me your fucking money.
What's over here?
What were they hiding from?
Down here.
They're hiding anything?
Oh, it's like a little checkpoint!
Oh, it's a secret tunnel!
Who's that?
Goodbye.
This map was just...
And he's gone now.
I got a little secret!
This guy was just checking his phone and was like, oh my god, I'm gonna die!
Oh...
I have a new message!
Yeah!
Getting lost and having a backdrop would be a pain.
Let's see...
Gotta go here.
There's apparently more people over there.
Does my tank fit through?
It does!
Oh my god, guys, I can't believe I just got promoted.
Pew!
Oh...
Did you guys hear that?
Just like...
Did you hear that over there?
I do!
I wonder what can that be?
Oh wow!
Oh god, he's upstairs?
Oh, I cannot aim there.
Alright.
The longest run of your life.
Nice, alright.
Must have been the wind.
Alright, next base.
Where's the next base?
Where is it?
Oh, it's over here.
How the fuck do I get there?
How do I get there?
How the fuck do I get here?
Okay, this I assume is here.
Uhhh... I need to figure...
How the fuck... How the fuck do I get there?
Is it from here?
Oh, it's on the other side of the water!
Oh, whoops.
Oh, whoops!
Uhhh... wrong side!
Wrong... wait, no, right side!
Wait, no, I can just get through from the water here.
Okay.
I just need to hover.
Hover time!
There's another area right there that I can hover.
Whoopsie-sand!
I can't tell!
The map is so difficult!
It's not a me issue, it's the map!
The map issue!
The map is so difficult to read!
Alright.
Up we go.
Guys, that bridge, there was a gap in there.
You don't understand.
You didn't see it, but my gamer eyes, I could tell.
There was like a huge gap in between, so there was no way to get across that bridge.
I know you guys can't see it.
Because you don't have the gamer eyes like me.
But there was...
Alright, let's see.
There they are.
Oh, wait, that was not big boss.
That was just some random...
That was just a random...
Random soldier's bot right there.
Alright, that guy's dead.
That was like, there's no way that guy died so fast.
It's a communal camp that's open to all travelers.
Yeah, including me.
Talk about convenient!
Alright, where's the...
Where's the main guy?
Is that the main guy?
Oh, that is.
Okay.
Wait, no.
Oh, that's the main guy!
Okay.
Phew!
Yeah, you think you're stronger than me?
I really...
You know what?
I'm gonna overkill.
I'm gonna do it.
Can I do it?
Oh, shit!
What is up?
See?
I told you guys there was no bridge!
I told you!
What do you mean there was... I told you, you guys were like, wow Toki, you're fucking coping Toki.
There's a bridge right here.
I told you there was a hole!
Nobody believed my hole!
Nobody believed in me when I said there was a hole.
You guys were like, Toki, you're fucking coping.
You just crossed the bridge.
What bridge?
I blew that bridge up!
The bridge they spawned.
They were like, wow Toki, you crossed the bridge.
It was literally right next to you.
To be fair, I actually made that shit up about there not being a bridge because even I was like, wait, was there actually a bridge?
And then I was right.
I was just a psychic.
I knew...
I forewarned the bridge.
The missing bridge.
Alright, let's see.
I was just psychic.
I could read the future.
Let's see.
How do I use this laser?
Like, how do I use this?
I'm gonna use it for this one guy.
Oh!
That's how you... Oh my god, I'm so stupid.
That's how you use it.
Guys, I figured it out.
I figured out how to use the laser.
That's so cool!
Why couldn't I use that before?
Alright, let's get rid of...
Let's get rid of the little guys first.
Because these guys are very annoying.
Alright, where's the big guy?
Big guy, where are you?
There you are, big boy.
Oh, I missed.
But like, there you are for real.
Oh, I should heal.
Give me a sec.
I should really heal.
So we don't go through that issue again.
What the fuck are you doing?
Creating a desert?
A desert?
Okay, how did I miss again?
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, I was reloading.
I didn't even know I was reloading.
But I can't see so many things at once!
Okay.
Nice.
Easy!
So easy.
I think we took out all the enemies here.
I think so too, right?
Alright, let's head to the next base.
How do we go to the next base?
Can we go through here?
I can!
Oh my god!
The Kingly base!
Wait, I'm already here!
Where are they?
Wait, where are they?
Where's the bad guys?
Oh, there they are.
Oh, there's the bad guys.
Don't worry.
Sorry.
Whoops.
Oh, it's okay.
He can't go upstairs.
And I can't shoot down too.
Equivalent exchange.
Can I just roll down here?
My tank will be okay.
Yeah, my tank.
See, my tank's okay!
Wait, he blocked?
Wait, he can block!
That's illegal!
Fight me!
Come on!
What the fuck is he doing?
Wait, he's literally just blocking.
What is he doing?
Okay, now you fucking fight back!
Okay!
Oh, use the laser?
You're right.
I'm gonna do it.
I know how to use it now.
There we go.
Oh my god, that was instant.
That was actually just instant.
Alright, let's reload.
And then...
Alright, we gotta reload this one too.
Wait, is there another officer?
No, he just doesn't have HP because he's not important enough.
Just not important enough, man.
What can I say?
The fuck?
Why are you still alive?
Yeah, that's actually really good against bosses.
I think.
Head back to the command center.
I did it!
I saved the world!
The world being only Sandland.
But that's all that matters.
We really let loose!
With this, we should be able to delay their invasion.
Well, as long as that giant tank unit doesn't remobilize, that is.
Rosetta didn't show up at any of these battles.
Did she go back to Forestland?
Am I going back to Forestland?
Maybe.
I just got used to it.
The tank is unique as hers.
Probably can't be repaired out in the field.
Thankfully, that'll buy us some time.
Heh, nice one, Prince!
Wait,
that's not mine.
Wait, who is it?
Who's calling me?
Oh, new phone.
Who's this?
It's mine.
Finally got through, Princess.
Glad you're safe.
Wish you'd called me Sir Croa.
Good, anyway.
It's Doctor Croa.
It's like those people who are like, um, it's Doctor.
Wouldn't it be better to tell me now?
Never know who might be listening.
Can't say this on air.
Just hurry.
Believe me, he'll blow you away.
It's gonna blow me away.
Come on.
He wouldn't ask for help.
He'd be like, I'm gonna take this of us without cause.
Let's go.
I'll inform General Aray by radio.
Alright, I didn't get knighted just to be not called Sir.
Alright, let's see.
Where is he?
Where does he live?
Where the fuck?
What?
Is he in forest?
Oh, we have to go to forest land.
Alright, where is he?
Back point's in forest land?
At the walk?
Oh, wait.
No, I hit it.
Oh, no.
I have the treasure map on.
Okay, never mind.
I was gonna be like, no.
Don't make me walk.
We're back in the forest land with all these forest landers.
Okay, we need, uh...
We need to buy...
Oh, hey.
Got stuff?
We have premium steel.
We have premium steel!
And the AN drive for your mech is particularly fun.
Okay, that's right.
Oh, here's the AN drive.
Alright.
We need that.
Well, we don't really need any of these.
Alright.
Who constructs my stuff?
You guys.
Workshop man!
You have premium steel.
Oh, I need platinum ore.
Fucking, I keep forgetting about the platinum ore shit.
Oh!
Oh, wait.
We don't need that, actually.
Never mind.
Uh...
Are you not the upgrade guy?
Do I have enough to upgrade?
Parts.
Upgrade part.
I do!
I finally have enough platinum steel!
Max level.
Nice.
Uh...
Apparently...
It doesn't matter.
Okay, customize vehicle.
Uh...
Oh my god.
Oh, this...
Okay.
Uh...
What?
Legendary?
What level is it?
25?!
What the fuck?
I need to be level 25?
Holy shit.
Okay.
How much do I need for that?
I'm like...
I'm like five levels short.
Okay, upgrade vehicle.
Okay.
I need super hard croctor alloy.
I need a lot of super hard croctor alloy.
Where do I get that, though?
I don't even have it.
You can't even...
What even is it?
What the fuck is the...
What the fuck is a super hard croctor alloy?
And how do I get it?
Oh, level 20 plus is possible.
Post game?
So I just have to look at it?
I can just...
I have to look at the legendary parts and I can't do anything about...
That's so cruel.
That is so fucked up.
All I can do is look at it.
Oh, yeah.
No.
I need the battle armor.
What is the...
Oh.
Is this the andrive?
Alright.
Whoa.
Temporarily boost performance.
Enables long range cannon.
What does cannon...
Enable...
And this is a long range cannon.
I can just look at it and be like, I have this now.
I can't do anything about it, but I have it.
Up we go.
It's called eye shopping.
This way.
Hello guys.
Before we do anything and use the bathroom, I'll be right back.
Alright, I'm back.
I'm back guys.
Thank you for the super chats.
Valentine, Duck, Byte, Johnny, LostCore, Kaz, and...
Oh my gosh, I need to scroll up.
And Ellen!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, we're ready to talk General Kroa.
You're on my side now.
Yeah, it's me.
Oh my god, you're dead.
We're gonna find you dead.
Whoa.
Damn, we gotta learn from him.
Alright, maybe I was stretching the truth just a little bit.
But cross my heart, the stuff about King Jam is legit.
Where is my father?
Crump Army Research Lab.
And this information's reliable?
Very much so.
Kroa's subordinates helped us feed false information to the Forestland Army.
About the Resistance having a plan to rescue the King.
Okay.
With the slight exaggeration that they knew exactly where he was being locked up.
It spread like wildfire.
At which point, Bread quietly switched out the research lab guards for a team of his handpicked elites.
Oh, so that's how you found out.
I know.
So he's not guarded by nerds anymore.
Well, not like we have any choice.
How will you save him?
By going forward with a fake rescue mission.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
With the rest of our army, the five people again.
Oh my god, another, all out assault.
Me and my five people.
My father's being held in the crump army.
Another all out assault with five.
And that's where we'll be going, right?
Misdirection's the greatest weapon an outnumbered force has.
Diversion and infiltration, baby.
Same as always then.
Including us being stuck with the risky part.
I mean...
I want the three random guys they found on the street.
...will never be the best.
I mean, they're not even close to us.
We gotta speak.
Alright.
We did it.
We finished our mission.
That was fast.
Now we need to go to the army research lab.
Where is...
Oh, it's not that far.
Wait, never claimed this?
Well, I guess I gotta go here.
Uh, which is fast.
Okay, I assume this is the cliff.
Guys, I can read maps now.
I can do it.
I did it.
Okay.
Here we go.
And then...
It is this way?
Okay, there should be like a mountain to climb here.
Here?
What's this?
Oh my god, are those premium ores?
Wait!
That might be a premium ore right there!
Oh my god, we are running dry on the premium ore.
Careful, jam might be spread all over bread by the time you find it.
I'm thinking of the super chat deadpool.
Thank you.
I can read maps!
This is a premium ore?
Oh my god, it's just regular iron ore.
God dammit.
God fucking dam- what am I gonna do with goddamn- what am I gonna do with nighter ore?
Alright, here we go.
It's fine.
I think I'm going the right way, right?
Yeah, I am.
Thank god.
Oh my god.
It would be a little awkward if I wasn't reading the map right again.
Wait, so where is the camp?
Ow.
Should be a campsite here?
Where is it?
I have to unlock a campsite so I have like fast travel.
Where the fuck is the camp?
Oh there it is.
It's in front of me.
Nice.
Unlocked it.
Okay.
That's all I needed.
Dungeon!
Alright.
Here we go.
They should put those like tire spikes here.
That would like stop me instantly.
I'm surprised they don't put the tire spikes.
Oh no.
It's stealth time.
How the fuck?
How do I get here?
Oh shit.
I didn't resurrect!
There are people here!
I was just walking around being like, yay!
Okay.
I actually did not realize there were people here.
So that was awkward.
Okay.
Oh!
God damn it!
It's not fair!
How do I sneak again?
Alright.
Guys I don't remember how to sneak here.
Well, we ghost!
Nice.
I carried out 10 stealth attacks guys.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I sneak packed this guy.
You can't catch me if I'm on high ground!
Ah!
Okay.
We'll go high ground.
I'm gonna go high ground.
Alright.
There's only one guy in high ground.
Yeah.
The guards die of cringe.
God damn it.
I hate this stealth mission.
Because it makes you restart from the beginning.
Give me mini checkpoints of anything.
Please.
I'm stupid.
Where's my journalist mode when it comes to stealth missions?
This is why I'm not a thief anymore.
Exactly.
I wish you could select difficulties on certain modes.
If I had...
I would fucking suck it in and take journalist mode for stealth missions.
10?
That's so many for you.
How did you even get 10?
That's crazy.
I would take baby...
I will 100% take baby mode for stealth missions.
I am not afraid to be who I am.
Oh.
Two hours later.
Come on.
Why are you walking so far?
Oh.
There you are.
Give me the mini checkpoint.
I want it now.
I am definitely supposed to take high ground there.
Okay.
There he is.
Standing there.
Wait.
There's multiple people there.
How do I scare multiple people?
Do I have to go down?
How the fuck do I scare multiple people?
Is he seeing me over here?
If I...
What?
No!
That was so fast!
I was trying to judge the...
Okay.
That's great.
I guess I have to go downstairs now.
Oh my god.
That's so not fair.
There were two people there.
Okay.
I'm going to scare him.
Can I do this?
Is there something here?
Can I just go behind them here?
What the fuck?
What is this place?
What do I...
What do I do here?
There's something special here?
Oh wait.
What?
Am I supposed to be here?
Like...
Where am I?
Am I supposed to be here?
Like... Okay.
There's a shell plane here.
I don't know if I'm supposed to go that way.
Or this way.
I'm so confused.
I'm risking it.
Alright.
Oh.
Where am I?
Where did I go?
I don't know.
I don't know where I went.
I'm following the yellow area.
I'm going off route.
God damn it!
That's so unfair.
I don't see that next to me.
I saw me.
Gotta be more careful.
Okay.
Oh it is!
It is!
This is the way we're meant to do.
We're off the grid!
We're going off grid!
As I follow the yellow marker!
Where did the yellow marker go?
No!
Where do I go when there's no...
Oh there it is!
Okay.
This way.
What the fuck!
God damn it!
That's bullshit!
Okay thank god.
I saw me.
Gotta be more careful.
Alright.
Whew!
God damn camper!
Alright we did it.
That was the route we were supposed to go.
Oh.
Downstairs?
This room is downstairs.
Alright down the stairs we go.
Oh.
Oh there they are!
Wait they made it?
How did you guys get there before me?
Why did you guys tell me how to...
What pathway did you guys go?
I'm not getting out.
You mean...
Oh Jem!
Can you open this?
I could do this in my sleep.
This is...
Just a little wiggle here...
Where your dad is?
Dad!
He better be like super hot if he managed to catch the demon as a wife.
What?
Or like really smart.
Or like really nice person.
What the fuck?
Fuck?
Do you know...
His sister settled for him?
Of course I do, Anne.
There's no way I'd fail to recognize my one and only daughter.
Just...
It's Peter Griffin.
Just a dad.
Bro that doesn't even look like a king.
He looks like some...
Some fucking office man worker.
That's the most...
Sad dad I've ever seen.
I'm sorry.
This has to be an emotional moment.
Were you the ones who...
Bro he looks like a fucking...
Like he's off to work at the office.
He looks like a fucking salary man.
Not a king.
He just clocked out.
He looks like a god damn salary worker.
All we really did was bring her here.
The dadliest dad.
I'm sorry.
The most stupid I've ever seen.
Just clocked out.
Long ago?
And...
He looked after this too.
Oh...
Lilith's necklace.
Yes but...
Mother is...
Is she dead?
I heard what happened to her while I was in prison.
Lilith...
I still can't believe it.
He just left his 9 to 5.
But considering you have to...
He's a king!
Why you don't be a king?
Is like business casual?
Business casual king?
At least Bradley was in uniform.
You do?
And it's real?
Yeah.
We've been gathering it all up.
To keep bread from getting his hands on.
Clocked out of prison time.
This certainly is a quanium.
Yeah.
See?
Whoa!
What happened?
Huh?
What's going on?
Hey!
Where are you going?
Business king.
He's business king.
I don't know.
My body is just moving by itself.
What's going on?
No.
Please stop her.
Not gonna lie.
Nobody...
No.
Don't go.
Oh no.
King Jeb, please.
That's your daughter.
Why are you so calm?
Oh shit.
What gives?
That kick was on another level.
That scrawny girl actually hurt Prince?
Was she always that strong?
Is she ok?
Is she a thorn?
A thorn.
Am I?
Princess.
Thorn.
Is that what it is?
Oh!
Why wouldn't he control the demon instead of the fucking girl?
Oh, he can only control humans!
He shot a child.
Oh my god.
What?
Wait, he can't control demons?
That's an angel?
Oh my god.
He is controlling the demon!
Oh my god!
I gave him the wrong ideas!
I mean, they're pretty good ideas, but like, not to the enemy!
I don't think he's human.
He has to be an angel then.
Because he's like, I'm gonna turn you to a path of righteousness.
And let's go!
Let's go!
But...
It's fine!
Just go!
No.
I trust you.
Oh my god, bro, what?
Bro, he's being controlled right now.
He's like, no.
You can't fight the control!
That's like so much...
That's like so much, like, gamble right now.
Now, let's do this.
I'll blow you into outer space!
Don't worry.
I got a tank.
Give me a sec.
I can't put my tank out.
Oh, okay.
Nevermind.
I gotta fight you with my fists.
Child versus child.
Take that!
That's right, child!
So far so good.
Here we go.
Oh shit.
Take that!
I don't remember how to normally fight, but I can smash buttons!
But I know how to mash.
That's fucking right.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm just funny.
If Tekken has taught me anything, just be unpredictable.
That's fucking right.
And I can drink water.
I don't know how to drink water.
Guys, how do I drink water to the game?
I don't remember how to hydrate!
Guys, how do I hydrate?
Guys, we need to hydrate!
We need to hydrate!
Guys, I can't drink water!
Guys, how do I drink water?
Okay, dark energy repair kit.
Oh no.
Oh no, okay.
How do I... oh, health drink.
Oh thank god.
Okay, we got the health drink.
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Guys, I figured it out.
I don't know how to drink water, but I figured this out.
No!
Oh, this is awkward.
This is awkward.
Give me a... oh!
Okay.
We're drinking all the heals right now.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
I don't remember how to drink water!
No!
He jumped!
That's not fair!
Oh god.
That was not fair.
He fucking jumped.
Like, how the fuck was I supposed to deal with that?
This is... all the fucking thing was for this.
Oh my god.
Were these fumbos?
Please, I'm trying!
I was in a tank for 90% of my life!
It's not fair!
I was literally riding a tank!
I didn't know how to use my fists!
Oh god.
Okay, thank god.
We have another one.
Nice.
Shit, I brought some heals too, child.
I blocked everything with my face.
I'm okay.
Oh yeah, and all my heals too.
Guys, I'm a bounty hunter, not a fist hunter.
Okay, I was gonna say not a fist hunter, but then I realized maybe I shouldn't say that.
I'm a bounty hunter, not a fist hunter.
Oh, I got picked up!
Wait, what?
Wait, where's Anne?
And where's his dad?
What are you doing, thief?
And where's Anne's old man?
Yeah.
Behind you.
Is he in my tank?
Wait, who's driving?
It's my tank!
Anne said she wanted to give it a try.
She'd better not get my tank all beat up.
Yeah.
No cars allowed in my tank.
That was close, Prince.
Muneo had you up against the wall back there.
And get all the cooties in there!
There's no way he's a human.
He's much too powerful.
Yup, you got that right.
Because he's not human.
What?
Then what is he?
He's an angel.
He's a demon?
If there's demons, there's angels.
No.
Muneo is...
an angel.
No way!
Oh my plot twist of the century that we read like 30 minutes ago!
Really?
Long ago, everyone...
you have all had to bear so much over the last 10 years.
This is not a king.
You've been through it.
I'm sorry I put you through this.
You're just like a regular dad!
You're an angel!
What's wrong with you?
He looks like a regular dad!
I'm sorry I put you through this.
I like how everybody has their outfits are like, what's it called?
Like, um, Semi-fantasy Mad Max-style type deal.
And then he just looks like some guy from 2024 just working from the office.
He must be tired.
Please, get some rest.
You must be tired.
He looks like an isekai person.
You got isekai from the office.
Indeed.
We did it!
We reunited with King Jam and Anne!
Yeah, post-apocalyptic outfits and then there's fucking King Jam.
Being like, just clocked out!
From my 9 to 5!
Just got out from my 9 to 5, guys!
It's great.
Let's see... where do we have to go?
Who do we have to talk to?
Over there?
How do we get... oh.
Okay, we go from here.
He's the family king.
He's king of the office.
He was a prisoner for 10 years?!
And the big red will take the king's escape sitting down.
We have to protect King Jam and the last of the Equanium.
But the radar only showed 4 spots.
The fifth is a mystery.
I know, how does his hair...
They just be like regular...
He's an angel guys.
The angel was like...
Time for your regular haircut.
And grooming.
How did he magically keep such a clean hair...
like... mustache for 10 years.
You mean you know where the Equanium is?
You know what the Equanium is?
My dad?
What am I, chopped liver?
True.
I knew it!
Ask me the dad!
I mean, your sister's dead.
Oh my god, yeah!
How did you like hook up with his sister?
I wanna know, how did you hook up with his sister?
Tell the child!
Hi!
Welcome to Tamaya Farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Wait, she's not pink!
Look, you can't just say that.
You can't just say why she's not pink.
See, he's wearing a uniform!
Now that looks, okay, the upside, the glasses and the mustache and that not really look like a king.
But the bottom half looks like a king now.
Now he looks official.
Oh, is this the queenium?
It has an age in 10 years, that's true.
I can't believe they let him have hair dye too, to keep his hair.
Oh, that's Lilith!
Oh, she has the fusion earring.
Oh my god,
this weapon mass destruction.
It's so beautiful!
The queenium?
That incredibly dangerous material that produces immense energy?
Lilith has been alive for millennia.
If she recognizes it, I'm sure she's right.
He's a mill hunter.
Perhaps the previous king kept it in the event of an emergency.
You know, I've heard rumors that the queenium was the cause of that terrible explosion in Sandland.
All those rumors.
I think we should hide it.
Respect.
If bread knew of its existence, he'd surely use it as a weapon.
So we can't keep it close to him.
I mean, that's a lot of pressure for him, you know?
For his wife to be around for a millennia?
That's gotta be a lot of pressure for him.
You couldn't ask your father to keep it safe?
King Lucifer.
How did she hide her pointy ears?
Like... like she got everything under disguise but the pointy ears.
What would the people say about that?
Of course not.
To be honest, she has a point.
I can't imagine a safer place to keep it.
And don't you worry about the key either.
I'll keep it as close as ever.
Then she dies.
And that's...
What happened?
Did your father tell you about any of this?
Did you know about this, thief?
We finally figured out what she looked like!
This is the first I'm hearing of this.
Wait, how does she have blonde hair?
Where the f- Wait a minute!
Anne has blonde hair, Lilith has red hair, and Jem has black hair!
Wait a minute!
I just- I just- You ruined it!
Something doesn't add up.
I just noticed.
Yeah.
Wait a minute, Anne!
I can't believe my necklace was the key to the aquarium chest.
It's fucking weird shaped.
So like, we had a feeling it was a lock for something.
Well, as long as it's been left by my dad, it's in safe hands.
So we've been going around collecting aquarium like mad for nothing?
Well, it's still a dangerous material.
What do you mean?
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Even if we have to give up on reactivating Gaara, it gets to do terrible damage just by using it for its explosive properties.
We have to find the aquarium for the other people.
So there's no change in our to-do list even with my father freed.
I like things nice and simple.
We'll get rid of that stupid angel and get the aquarium back.
Yeah!
Which stupid angel?
Wait, there's more than one?
Okay.
Wait, Moonio's an angel?
What?
Was she not there?
Makes sense.
Lady Lilith wouldn't lose to a human.
Mother.
Well, we'll need to replenish our energy if we want to.
Oh, she was in the tank?
Oh yeah!
I'll take a spot on the floor too.
I almost forgot she was in the tank.
I thought she was with us.
I always assumed she was always with us for some reason.
Even though she was driving...
Even though we all heard her driving the tank.
I was like, she's with us, guys!
Oh wait, there's stuff here.
Okay.
Hit the hay.
How do I...
Oh, I have to go back.
Wait, where is...
How do I get up there?
I guess this way?
Oh, it's this way.
Okay.
I was gonna say...
How do I get to the fucking sleeping quarters?
Okay, I'm gonna rob you guys.
Boop!
My stuff now!
My friend's the queen.
Or the princess.
I mean, she's practically the queen now.
So I can rob you guys.
Cause that's my friend's stuff.
Wait, how did you get here?
What?
Weren't you downstairs?
Oh, Prince.
Are you going to sleep already?
Yeah.
Yeah, I am.
Goodnight.
What was that?
Oh yeah, she's my niece.
Yeah, that's right.
That means I can steal everything.
Everything that's here is mine.
What happened?
Yeah, what happened?
Oh, now he's in the outfit?
Now he's not a...
Oh my god, finally!
Okay, now he sort of fits in.
Gone!
Oh my god, gone!
Are you sure?
Maybe you just put it down somewhere.
That's not it!
I left it on my pillow, but now I can't find it anywhere!
On your pillow?
You took it off?
What now?
He's gone!
Eppy's gone!
Eppy?
Who's Eppy?
What?
How could you let him escape?
Oh, it's the General!
I didn't let him escape, he just got away!
Yeah, why would you take it off?
It's the same thing, you idiot!
And the day after King Jam told us what it does.
The timing's far too convenient to be coincidental.
There's a spy.
Do you think it was Eppy who stole the necklace?
It has to be, because Eppy wasn't there to listen to us.
Knowing Eppy, I wouldn't put it past him.
There's a spy here.
It could be you.
It could be me.
It could even be...
I'll give it a shot.
I can think of a few routes he could have taken.
Prince, we're going back to Sandland.
No!
What the fuck?
I was only in Forsyth for like ten seconds!
The first place they'll go is Demon Village.
So?
My dad's there.
He'll take care of it.
When it comes to Aquanium, we can't take anything from it.
Oh, Raul!
Sounds like a waste of time to me.
Why do we keep going back to Sandland?
I thought we were free from Sandland!
And then they put me back into the sand!
Every time!
You can never leave Sandland.
Okay, we gotta get his HP up, that's for sure.
Oh, I have four skill points?
I was not paying any attention.
Okay.
We're gonna raise the Darkness attack.
And...
We're gonna raise the Darkness.
And we're not gonna do anything regarding the rock.
Because I have no idea how to use the rock.
And then, oh my god, we can finally upgrade you, Anne.
Recover HP increases?
Okay, we need to increase that.
And then...
Limit Time Boost consumes no energy.
Ooh, that's really good.
I'm gonna fucking upgrade all of Anne's stuff.
Recover HP for Beelzebub's vehicles?
Yes!
Appearant Breakdowns and other stats.
Insanely... Instantly reloads.
Ooh!
Instant reload ammo!
Reduces cooldown for quick reload.
Nice.
Okay.
That's really good.
Finally, actual useful skills.
Ginger, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Let's back to the sand.
Where's the mission?
So I have to go back to the sand.
Oh, there it is.
Is that it?
No, that's the flowers.
Oh, I always forget about the flowers.
Wait, where is the mission?
Oh, it's over here.
The demon village.
God, it's so far.
Dad, I'm home!
I'm home, Dad.
Did you miss me?
I brought your...
Uhhh...
Grammys?
No, your grandchild!
I brought your grandchild!
Hell!
Wait, it's not supposed to be like this?
Oh, I assumed it was supposed to be like this because it's like hell.
I thought it was supposed to be like that because it's hell!
I didn't realize it was not supposed to.
Gremlin, what's going on?
The human piloted bot dropped bug monsters all over the villains!
Oh, it's the bug things!
I've never seen creatures like them in Sand Land before.
Yeah, but it's where the demons live!
The attackers went for the underground ruins.
You go on ahead, Prince.
I'll join you once I get patched up.
Okay.
I have to go this way.
Oh my god!
I honestly thought that's what hell was supposed to look like.
Are you okay, Slime?
Slime, are you okay?
Oh my god, he's gonna evaporate!
Wait, is this the guy that likes the singing?
No, that's a different guy.
Alright, it's this way.
Oh, no.
We gotta...
We gotta hope Dad's okay!
Is up down?
Yeah, up is down.
Okay, I always have to remember if up is down.
Dad, are you okay, Dad?
Dad!
Sorry, I was trying to see it.
I forgot to run.
Dad!
I have your grandchild here!
RUN!
It's the last piece of live that we have!
What
are you doing?
Attack him as one!
Quique-quique-quique!
Dammit!
The final piece of Aquanium...
is so close!
Moonia!
Can you confuse your heart with manipulation?
Wait then, who's Bred?
Is Bred also an angel?
I'm already using it but...
Yeah, because we got a baby angel.
Baby angel!
Not the widescreen TV!
Oh yeah!
Oh yeah, he was like the cyborg guy.
I forgot.
Sorry, he's so forgettable as a character.
Okay, you broke his TV!
Like, you broke into his home and broke his TV!
Like...
And he's the bad guy?!
What the fuck?!
He...
Wait!
Is he...
Is he mad because his revenge is based off the TV?!
He started an entire war because he broke a guy's TV!
What a story.
That's the plot!
Poor TV!
Millions of people died!
Water was...
Was withheld from an entire country because an angel got beat up because he broke a devil's TV!
He killed Lilith!
BABBA!
WATCH OUT!
Dad, no!
You're done!
It was a smart TV!
Doki!
You don't understand!
Millions of people died...
Because of a TV.
No!
Such toughness!
I never dreamt the King of Demons could be this good!
Bro, this guy is literally the king of demons!
What do you mean?!
Brad!
His favorite show is gonna air.
He got the- wait.
Oh no!
What?
Oh my god!
Not the ceiling, Earn!
Where did he get that?
The bird!
No!
He's gonna eat- what the fuck?!
He just ate him!
What the fuck?
And while I'm at it, I might as well get rid of his bread too, huh?
What?
You little twerp!
He just ate Lucifer?
It's that easy?!
Stand back, everyone!
You can just eat Lucifer?
Oh no, not again!
Not round two!
Oh no!
I don't ever give in to an angel shrimp like you!
This is bad, guys.
I was not ready for- I was not ready for round two of this!
I did not stock up!
No!
I didn't stock up!
Guys!
I didn't stock up on his!
Oh, this- I'm so fucked.
Guys, how do you block again, guys?
I don't remember.
I thought- I thought- I thought I'd be using my tank!
What is this?!
Just give in already.
Oh no!
What do you mean I can't use my tank?!
Here it comes!
Oh god.
Where are my allies?!
Do you think a fiend like you ever stood a chance against an archangel?
Okay, nice.
Archangel my butt, you little runt!
Oh my god!
There's other attacks!
I figured it out!
Where did I figure it out?
So far, so good!
Oh shit!
I figured it out!
There's other attacks, guys!
You angel runt!
Oh my god, guys!
I figured it out on the floor!
Here we go!
Oh my god!
Let's go!
I figured out the other movesets!
Guys, I'm doing better!
Holy shit!
Here we go!
The last pause!
Let's fucking go!
Look!
After getting spoiled with tank!
Nah.
After vanquishing Lucifer, you lot aren't even worth it.
I'm playing Tekken!
Huh?
You're beneath me!
Insectmen are more than enough to do this!
I beat your ass!
Child!
Hey!
Get back here!
You really won because you ate my dad!
What the fuck?
Why is he herb-er?
Looks like all the other equations.
Why didn't you make an herb-er bug?
It looks like the price is ours.
Then, let's be on our way.
What the fuck is Garum?
Walks away.
Looks like we gotta take care of these guys first.
Can I bring my tank now?
Am I allowed to have my tank?
Oh, thank God!
Oh, thank God, thank you!
Oh, my God!
Thank you!
Why could I bring this earlier?
Okay, not gonna lie, why couldn't I not?
Why couldn't I not bring this earlier to the fight?
This does not make sense.
Holy shit, he's literally just one hit!
Yeah, like, the insect men are so scary.
Alright.
Why bro looking like Salazar from Resident Evil 4?
Dr. Crabbear, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, my God, he does!
So you can't trust him.
I was like, what is this little twerp doing?
Kick his ass.
I'm king now!
Bro, you just found out he's your grandpa.
This is it!
It's over!
I'm sorry about Lady Lilith, but the King of Demons has not been taken out.
Yeah, cause I'm king now!
From what Mooniel said, that urn only seems capable of sealing Lucifer away.
The King of Demons may be trapped, but he should still be alive.
Probably.
So if we take the urn back from that brat, we can still fix this?
How do we take it?
It's literally getting digested right now.
He has to use the bathroom!
Do angels need to use the bathroom?
We'll find out soon!
We've gotta let the Trick Camp guys know about this.
Okay.
I'll contact him right away.
What do we have to do?
Go back to the camp.
Alright.
We gotta find out if angels need to use the bathroom.
What do you mean, don't you know?
It's an honest question!
How are we gonna get the urn out?
Alright.
We gotta go speak with everybody.
Alright, nice.
Wow!
That's a lot of stuff.
That's not tank related.
I don't need any of these.
Okay, we need to buy...
We need to buy HP.
We're running out of heals.
Alright, buy.
Okay, repair kit.
Repair kit plus.
Okay, we're gonna buy this.
And then we need to buy health serum.
Because we don't have that anymore.
Oh, we have so much money!
That's good.
Alright.
We gotta replenish on this.
Uhhh... I guess I'll...
Uhhh... We'll buy firepower.
Oh, wait.
No.
Actually, let's get max firepower.
Alright, there we go.
Thank you.
No problem.
Alright, we gotta talk to him.
Up we go.
Okay.
Climb up the ladder, bells.
Climb up the ladder, bells!
Okay.
Okay, we gotta tell Longo.
Alright.
It's come down to this.
We must put everything on the line to stop Garm's reactivation.
Is it even possible?
Yeah, it's possible.
This is the most destructive weapon in history.
Jesus!
Which once sunk an entire continent.
The flying fortress, Garm.
Oh yeah, flatlands.
And there's only one way inside it.
That's a giant hole.
I know.
I was like, what the fuck?
You have to make your way to the lowest level of the Masala dig site where it's buried.
And use the tunnel to its entrance there.
But, with Bread and Muriel already headed for Garm.
Jesus.
Sorry, I had to look at something.
Their defenses will be so packed that not so much as a single plant could see through.
We must be prepared to make sacrifices on our side.
Though any member of the resistance...
See?
They're just like the rebel army.
There's no more frightening enemy than one that doesn't know fear.
Doesn't quite ring true coming from the man who won that war.
I lost that war as badly as you did.
Yeah, nobody won in that war.
Literally entire cotton that is gone.
Alright.
Then we gotta...
Talk to...
We gotta talk to whoever's over there.
I guess like the dad?
Office dad?
Office king?
Office king!
I don't know why I would tell you about what's going on.
So even Lucifer has been bested.
There's not a safe place left in this world.
Then we'll make one.
That's what we've been fighting for, right?
Hmm.
Though considering how many times I've almost lost hope, maybe that's not very convincing coming from me.
The people around us are the same as they were then.
Ash, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is Doki Bird from Bumpland?
Yeah!
That's where I'm from.
I wish Lilith could have seen the person you've become.
Father...
Let's give them some alone time.
Yeah.
This might be the last time they see each other.
Huh?
What?
Wait, what do you mean by that, Bizzlebug?
Uh... nothing.
The last time?
Who's gonna die?
What do you mean by that?
Somebody gonna die?
Oh my gosh.
I coded it wrong.
Go down the ladder.
Alright.
Who else do I need to talk to?
Can I tell the swimmer?
Where'd they left?
Are they running away or are they joining us?
Oh, okay.
They're joining us.
I thought they like left us and they ran away.
I'll be leaving soon myself.
King Jam, I leave this place in your capable hands.
If there's anything I can do...
No.
This is your fight.
I'll be praying for your safety.
Swimmers, move out!
Alright!
Yeah!
Good luck to you.
You too.
We'd better get going as well.
Anne, I need you to come back alive.
I'll be fine.
Whose daughter do you think I am?
Yeah.
She can talk to animals.
Have we even used like her animal powers?
Like other than that one time?
And she's our king's granddaughter and princess' niece at that.
The fact that she can talk to animals but we only used it once?
I'm not going to put it that way.
Beelzebub.
Rao.
I won't ask you to protect her.
Just try not to let her be too...
You killed all the animals.
Who is she going to talk to?
Understood.
She talked to the flying dino too.
Did you...
That?
Alright, let's see.
Can I upgrade anything?
I don't know.
Just double checking.
Can I upgrade my... Yeah, everything's maxed out now.
Customize.
Apparently, these don't matter.
This gun is like the best overall so I'm not going to worry then.
I'm just surprised I haven't got any of these... any better stuff here.
Bro, these guys.
25.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I had a rough day today but after watching your stream, I feel better now.
Thank you so much and good luck with the rest of the stream.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat, 25.
I hope you feel... I'm glad you feel a lot better now.
And I'm glad to cheer you up.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, here we go.
We go straight to it.
I can feel the final hours of Sandland.
Alright, is it down there?
Is it all the way down there?
Alright, we're just going to jump down.
Oh my god, it is.
Alright, I can do this.
Okay, never...
Let me do the proper way I guess.
I guess the game did not want me to jump down.
How the fuck do I get there?
Okay.
I'm trying to figure out how to get there.
I guess from here to a flip.
How the fuck do I get down?
What the hell?
Get down from here?
I wish I was any good at sensing things like that too.
Not that bad.
Okay.
Alright.
Apparently not.
Apparently gravity is saying no today.
What about from here?
Okay.
I'm just trying to test the limits.
Guys.
I just want to know what...
Which one would...
Gravity has to have a stopping point at some...
That's...
Somewhere.
Toki, please.
Oh no!
I just thought gravity was going to stop working.
They force you to listen to the dialogue.
This is so...
...developed military technology.
One upside of the Royal Army's iron fist is that it didn't need to fight many actual wars.
Only a small fraction of the Royal Army was dedicated to making technological advancements.
Oh, so that's why.
Wait.
So, Forrest Land was always at war with others?
And then Sand Land just existed?
It was only at war with itself.
It's kind of ironic that it takes war to push forward technology.
Ow.
That makes sense.
Oh, hey!
There's a stop here.
Alright, let's see.
What the fuck are these lizards doing here?
There's so many.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Let me loot.
Oh god!
Oh god.
Okay.
It followed me home.
Here we go.
That's right.
You made a big mistake.
You made a big fucking mistake.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
You're sure not to go in so deep that you can't touch the bottom, Prince.
So, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
More Doki House.
Sand Land!
We're almost...
I don't know if we're close to done, but I think we're almost done.
I think we're at the final arc now.
Not long now.
Supreme Commander.
Rosetta?
I thought I owed you to see to our defense.
Yeah.
What are you doing here?
Forgive me.
You don't deserve to be on flat land.
There is something I would like to confirm with you.
Yes?
You once said if we were able to reactivate Garum, it wouldn't be used against the Resistance.
Please tell me that is still true.
King Jam and Princess Anne are among them after all.
Oh, I see.
Oh, she's going to turn to our side.
Garum shall not be fired within our borders.
However, if they flee to Sand Land and continue to oppose us, that's...
Hey, that's not part of the deal.
She's like her childhood friend.
You're telling me you still haven't found the Resistance?
Flush them out and burn them to ashes!
What do you mean?
Like he was there.
What is he?
You know where the resistance... he literally lived there.
Also, where did all these other people came from?
He has more medals!
Where are your medals, Rosetta?
Oh my gosh!
He insulted our queen!
Oh my god, that's so fucked up!
Oh, this is some Scar shit right here.
I'm just gonna...
Eliminate them!
Not as fast though.
The nerve of him.
I know, right?
So fucked up.
Wow.
What an army.
What could I possibly do?
What are they gonna do?
Slide up to me?
Okay.
Goodbye.
What?
What is that?
What defense?
The world's in serious trouble.
If something like that takes off...
Weeoo!
Nothing's gonna stop us now!
What defense they have!
Weeoo!
Oh shit!
Okay, it's okay.
I made it through.
It's okay.
My bike is okay.
Don't worry.
Oh my god.
We're here.
How did they do it?
Weeo!
How did she do it?
Oh shit.
We have to claim that...
Okay, we got to claim that real fast.
All right.
This is a little awkward.
Give me a sec.
Guys, we need to claim the little...
We need to claim... Okay, don't worry, that's not gonna hurt us.
Weeoo!
Oh shit!
My bike!
No!
I got greedy!
I wanted to claim the... the... No!
Do I have to do that again?
Oh my god, I have to do that again!
I got greedy!
No!
It's okay, I can dodge all of this again.
Oh no, not again!
I got so greedy!
I wanted to get the checkpoint!
The water!
I wanted to get the water!
It's okay, like they're not really a threat.
I literally just... I don't understand, like...
Am I supposed to stop them?
Am I supposed to beat those mechs up?
Like...
I don't know.
Why did I do that?
Why can't I just ride past it?
Okay, I wanted to claim this.
Yay!
I got the camp!
Give me a sec, guys!
Did I claim the camp?
I did it!
Woo!
It's okay.
Oh god!
That's not okay!
It's alright.
Riding past it again.
Oh!
Guys, I got it!
I got the water!
We did it, guys!
Him again?
Don't worry.
I got a strong... Oh my god!
Wait a minute!
Wait, what?
Why is it so strong?
Where is he?
Where did he go?
Oh, there he is!
Holy shit!
He has so much HP now!
Oh my god!
Yeah, he has lasers too!
He's 3.0!
He's at his 3.0 debut!
Oh god!
Oh, he is strong.
I'm gonna use the explosive lasers.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna make sure I line it up though, properly.
Wait, where did he go?
Where the fuck did he go?
Oh, there he is!
Okay.
No!
Are you fucking... He dodged my explosive lasers!
That's actually bullshit!
He actually dodged the explosive lasers!
I can't believe it.
I... Are you serious?
Are you serious?
Oh...
I can't believe he dodged it.
He's so good!
He walked to the left!
I can't believe it!
And does he do that?
That should be illegal!
Oh my god!
I still can't believe he walked to the left and like, fucked me over.
That's fine.
I literally can just stay here.
He sidesteps!
That should be illegal!
There we go.
Alright.
Oh!
I truly did it!
I should've aimbot you, right?
I should've used my aimbot!
There we go.
Oh!
We have it again!
Wait!
I shouldn't...
Oh god.
Okay.
Okay, watch this.
Can't dodge this now.
BOOM!
I take like a hundred damage but can't dodge this!
You fool!
I'll let daddy's girl Rosetta finish you while I watch from a safe distance!
Wait, what?
I'm gonna fight Rosetta now?
Alright.
Where am I supposed to go?
How the fuck do I get there?
Did I came from here?
Where did I come from?
Where do I go?
Where do I come from?
Oh, this way.
Alright.
Yeah.
What was going on with him?
I'm just gonna shoot him from the distance.
I am... there's no need for me to be there.
See?
Alright, get over here.
Oh my god!
How are you still alive?
Alright, you guys.
You guys are gonna get there soon!
I believe!
Don't worry, you're gonna get there soon!
There we go.
Nice.
Alright.
Wait, what?
Tough?
Okay, okay, Beezo, but we...
We've been... this has been a breeze so far.
Okay, don't worry.
Is he dead?
Nice.
I'm gonna go get him.
And then we'll get rid of him.
This might be a little overkill, but that's okay.
Shooting the cannon might be just a little overkill.
Just a little bit.
What's over here?
I feel like I should go here though.
Okay.
It's nice that I can use this from afar.
Alright, now they're getting closer.
But like, it's so nice that I can use this from afar.
Like, it still works.
It still works.
And then...
Boom.
Okay, now reload.
And...
Oh, okay, he's dead.
Alright.
Now where do I go?
Sound there.
Wait, I could've just drove down.
I did not have to...
Guys, I made a mistake.
Do not just drive down, guys!
Do not just drive down!
Guys, don't just drive down!
We've learned!
We can learn from mistakes!
We can...
Alright.
Alright, gravity has sort of forsaken me.
What the fuck?
We're gonna do a little pistol gun.
When you heal again.
Alright.
Guys, I don't know if you guys know this, but like...
In this world, there's something that we like to call gravity.
And sometimes, it is a good idea not to...
Not to let gravity win!
Alright, nice.
And...
I'm just gonna get rid of these smaller guys too.
Wait, is he dying?
Wait, but they told me I don't kill!
That guy...
He said fading away!
His life is fading away!
Did I just kill a man?
No, I...
No, it's not me.
It's my tank.
Alright, get...
On this side.
Okay.
Pew!
Oh, wait, I didn't get rid of the tank yet!
Okay, now I got rid of the tank.
Pew, pew, pew, pew.
Alright.
Easy.
There's more?
Holy shit!
How much money do they have?
Why couldn't I use this to invade Sand Land?
Alright, nice.
Feels like they could have done so much by using all this to invade Sand Land.
Alright, we're almost there.
Why is this so slow?
Am I not using my...
I have so many questions.
Rosetta?
Because that is not worth that much.
Hey, Rosetta.
I'm eating my sandwich while you guys talk it out, ladies.
Oh, yeah?
I have a tank.
I mean, you have a bigger tank, but I have a tank.
Two.
Ooh.
That's a lot of sauce on my sandwich.
The end that I know is stubborn, a sore loser, and a crybaby.
Whoa!
You never would go easy on me back when we'd play games together.
Am I a crybaby?
Oh, I would.
I'm not.
You were just so weak that you still lost.
Well, not anymore.
We'll find out.
I'm not.
Oh, shit.
Hope you're not expecting me to start going easy on you now.
Wait, we're starting?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I thought that that two would be longer!
I thought that that...
I'm in the tank.
I'm in the...
But you haven't won a game.
Okay.
All right.
I'm in the tank now.
Now I'm in the tank now.
Okay, that was scary.
But I'm in the tank now.
I'm in the tank.
Don't get run over.
I wasn't... I didn't know she was gonna start.
I thought I had the longest time in the cutscene.
How the fuck... How was I supposed to know?
She almost road killed me.
No, she didn't.
She almost did.
Holy shit.
She did not let me chill.
She was just like...
She did not just ready, set, go.
She just went go.
You know how they're like, we're gonna start at three?
It's like they start at one.
Oh god.
That was a lot of damage.
That was... Okay, let's just heal a little bit.
Okay.
I almost got a taste of my own medicine, yeah.
Ral, get back in here, Ral.
Ral, get back in here!
Okay.
Laser!
Alright.
Oh, it's almost down.
It's almost down.
Phew!
It's almost one more hit.
One more hit!
Phew!
Okay, two more hits maybe!
Okay, maybe three!
Oh my god.
We're almost there!
Oh, it's looking at me.
I don't like it when it looks at me.
Oh, I got the boost!
The nitro!
Nice.
Finally.
Stand down!
Afraid I can't do that.
If you want to get past, it will have to be over my dead body.
No, Rosetta!
It doesn't have to be this way!
Hey!
B house!
What are you doing?
I'm grateful for your long lifespan, Fiend.
It will give me the chance to kill you in my next life.
Am I gonna slap her?
Oh, shit!
Come on!
Let's go!
Is her skull okay?
She's dead.
Bro,
I...
Guys, I...
Brain
damage!
That is... Okay.
Okay.
I like how... Alright, we're gonna not pay attention to that, I guess.
Oh my god.
That would have fucking... That is worse than a concussion!
It should be... Oh my god.
Oh my god.
We're actually thinking of the super chat.
Thank you.
The deadly forehead finger flip.
Oh my god.
What the fuck did I just witness?
That like... That is like... That... Oh, she gets into a coma.
That's lucky.
And she's not a vegetable by then.
Mm.
I thought she was gonna slap her.
A slap would have... Like, at least she'd survive.
How are you alive?
How do you not have brain damage?
What a pity.
Abby...
What are you doing here?
No, never mind.
That doesn't matter.
After them...
You have to...
What?
Such agitation.
I'll help you relax.
For a very long time!
What?
This is no time for games!
Abby...
You...
I'll give you a glorious death in battle.
To expunge the dishonor...
What?
... Of your defeat!
Did she die?!
Really?
She died from a bullet and not the head flick?
Her weakness was guns.
She died from a bullet but not the fucking flick to the head.
Okay.
Oh shit!
Okay, I'm just gonna grab this guy.
Where are you?
I think I punched him.
I can't see but I assume I punched him.
But that's my one weakness.
No!
I can't fit!
Let's fuck this.
I'm just gonna ride my way through.
Oh my god!
Okay, we gotta repeat.
Prepare this bike at least.
Still better wake up than be your clock tucked in the Zoom chat.
Thank you.
What the fuck?
Let's get on the bike.
The bike is the fastest.
What?
Oh, it activated!
Amazing!
This is amazing!
Indeed it is!
With this, our army will control the entire world!
And yours truly has risen to the post of second in command!
Now no one in the world can defy me!
He's like so insignificant.
Like, this story!
We were too late.
Can someone just get him a new TV?
We'll have to.
Run away!
I can't stand it.
How dare those worms put us in this mess?
This is such a fight.
That does it.
Soldiers!
Ready the main cannon!
Target our lower ports!
The main cannon?
That hasn't been tested yet!
How do they know how to run this?
Other than this soldier, this is their first time here!
They're not even educated to fucking run the Death Star!
Yes, sir!
Preparing to fire main cannon!
How are you?
Literally first day on the job.
They're like, we haven't even... we don't even know which buttons those are!
What are those buttons?
Main cannon!
That damn Mumio!
Has he lost his mind?
What manual?
This ship has been out of commission for like hundreds of years!
Energy at maximum!
Initiating countdown!
Thirty seconds!
Rosetta!
Are you alive?
You got shot!
And brain damage!
He's al- she's alive?!
Sorry, the flick was like... got her to like one- two HP.
The gunshot got her to one HP!
You know like Pokmon?
They withstand it because of their love for you?
That's what happened.
The power of love.
Jesus, crazy, uh, crazy danger.
Oh!
Woah!
Guys, I think Eppy's dead!
Bro, what the?
Oh my god, I think... guys, I think Eppy's dead!
Dead!
Oh my god, they're not serious!
Yeah, I don't think they can out run that!
Oh!
There he is!
Daddy!
Why?
That's the dad?!
Has we learned nothing!
Wait!
Is Eppie her dad?
Okay!
Oh, bread!
Oh, thank god!
Okay, I was like... Okay, it's... Okay, bread's the dad.
Okay, that's a lot better.
I was like, that's so fucked up if Eppie was the father.
Okay, bread's the dad.
Alright.
Oh, thank god.
I can't believe it!
All this happened because you got beat up by Lucifer for breaking his TV.
Clearly, Sandland had no water because he fucking broke into Lucifer's house.
Princess!
Thank goodness!
All four of you made it back safely.
All for the TV!
If the cannon was aimed towards us, we wouldn't have made it.
And the others?
We lost many of us in that attack.
Who died?
Uh... Mr. Rao.
Who is that in your car?
General Rosetta.
What?
Longo!
I can explain...
She's a childhood friend!
We're gonna be roommates!
And they were roommates.
I've done what I can.
Now...
The rest... is up to her.
Look after her.
Hey, can you check her brain?
See if there's brain activity?
I will.
They didn't even take off her uniform!
How are we giving her medical assistance?
She's still wearing maybe blood-soaked uniforms in there right now!
Like she was on the ground!
Take off the uniform and put her in something else!
The dirt is gonna get into her wound!
Is her skull in one piece?
That's a good question!
Is her skull in one piece after everything I did?
Save our queen!
Alright.
Alright, let's see...
Oh, yeah, go this way.
Alright, but... Oh, I was gonna say I need to use the bathroom, but I guess we'll do this cutscene.
I don't know.
But yeah...
Then you can count on her making it.
She's always been a tough girl after all.
Perhaps we can get some useful information from her when she wakes.
Are you going to keep fighting?
I've been thinking...
Maybe you could take...
The king was not fighting!
Like, he was just here at the base!
And just break away from anything you've worked for?
I'm not saying we don't stand a chance...
But...
We've lost so many allies already.
Who did we lose?
Like, soldier number three?
With no face?
A name?
I'm afraid that running away from here is the one thing I cannot do.
Fucking Rosetta lived!
Why not?
Oh, yeah, move to Spino so I can tax my people.
If I abandoned my people and homeland, what kind of king would I be?
Besides, we still have allies in the world.
And I've been waiting for them for ten years.
It's only fair that I wait for a time, too.
But...
Bread and his troops already know where you are!
They could obliterate this entire region if they fire Garim's main cannon at you!
That only makes it all the more important that I not leave.
As long as I'm here, Supreme Commander Bread might hesitate to fire on this location.
Even during those long years he kept me imprisoned, he always treated me with total respect.
Yeah, okay, they're going in assuming that Bread can control the psychotic angel.
My father!
And soldier number three did so much for us, Doki!
How could you say that?
He was my Oshi!
Every person born on this planet has a duty they must fulfill.
Mine is to be a stout tree under which all those seeking refuge here can find their way.
You did nothing for ten years!
Like...
Now, you must go fulfill your own.
You can talk about this responsibility when you were stuck in prison for ten years.
Just listen to your heart, Anne.
That is where you're sure to find your answer.
That's my girl.
Go on.
King James is a truly wise ruler.
We're gonna be heroes!
He's got nothing on the King of Demons.
Before we go with the final arc, I'm gonna use the bathroom.
How about that, guys?
We're almost done!
I know I said that like an hour ago, but this time, we're almost done.
I am back!
I'm back, guys.
Give me a sec.
Just gonna adjust some stuff real fast.
Oh!
The heck?
Why do I have like so many... Oh, okay.
Never mind.
I was like, why do I have so many messages?
Oh, it's about the...
Oh, yes!
It was about the...
Anime Expo stuff.
Also, thank you for the super chat!
Darkstar, Byte, Ginger, Risa, Hiro, Dark, Duck, Hey, Johnny, Maddie, Kaz, and Alan!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I guess you didn't know.
We're gonna have an extra guest for my karaoke at an expo.
And it's gonna be with Yuusan!
Yuusan's gonna be a bonus guest at my karaoke.
And we're gonna have some duets and some solo songs.
So, yes!
I'm getting carried.
I'm gonna be on Yuusan's backpack as they carry me in karaoke.
But yeah, that was what the message... I was like, what the fuck?
20 messages?
Why do I have 20 messages?
So, yeah.
I had to double check.
They were just talking about the announcement for it.
Alright, and what do you wanna say?
Oh, yeah, okay.
I gotta buy stuff?
Okay.
I'll buy a shield.
You're not fighting shit.
You're just staying in my tank and repairing it.
And protect everyone who supported him.
That's why I want to be a beacon of hope for all of those who protected me.
I take it you found your answer?
Yeah.
The two of them are truly the sword and shield of forest land.
What about... what?
What about me?
Please... don't...
I did so much!
I'll never know.
What do you mean?
What about me?
In that case, we must return to Sandland.
It's not always about you.
It's not me, me, me, me, me, okay?
We have to stop Red at all costs.
And we need the Royal Army's help for that.
I don't believe in forest land!
And that toad, Mooniel, too.
And we have to rescue the king of demons.
Oh.
Are we going back to Sandland?
Prince, you didn't forget about that, did you?
No, no, no!
Of course not!
We forgot about our dad?
That got warred in front of us?
Can't believe it.
Get out of there, Raul!
I gotta restock my stuff!
Alright, let's see.
Okay, we need a buy.
Okay, we have all the...
All the health.
So we need, like, repair kits.
Oh my god, we need so many repair kits.
Okay, we got repair kits.
Oh, let's grab some strength serum.
And then some...
Uh, firepower, too.
We'll grab firepower.
And... armor up.
Alright.
Gabriel, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
It's your birthday?
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Gabriel!
Yay!
Woo!
Alright.
Let's see.
I feel like I don't need to upgrade anything.
Unless I have, like...
Do I have a machine gun?
Do I have a better machine gun after... finally?
After years?
Let's check.
Uh, dragoons.
Nope.
Still the same old machine gun.
And you guys say my laser is, like, the best laser out of all of these.
So I believe you guys.
Oh my god.
But this one's 324!
Guys!
This one has 324!
Do I not take it?
It's, like, double!
Guys!
Is it not worth it?
But new laser, though.
But number big!
Oh, wait.
Uh...
But the number is big!
Number big!
Number...
Can it charge?
I guess not.
Okay.
Oh, the charge shot is bigger?
Oh!
It doesn't count the charge shot.
Okay, I trust you guys.
I will be back.
Father.
Lung.
I'll be back, guys.
Anne.
Roommate!
You...
Can't leave.
If the Resistance flees to Sand Land.
Father said he'll wipe you out with garum.
Red will attack anyway.
Whether we go or not.
No.
That's not what my father wants.
Come on, Rosetta.
If she's talking a little slower than usual, we know why.
We might have fixed her bones, but I don't think you can get back brain cells.
It's just... very lonely.
Lonely?
He has no friends?
Wait.
I'm going to... take...
We can't let you go before you answer some questions.
He's just Mr. He murdered thousands of people, but he was so lonely.
You don't understand.
He has no friends.
I just... want more time.
Time?
I should have died... back at the Masama Dixite.
Oh, they should have died like at least two times.
But that tyke... didn't finish me off.
Who you calling a tyke?
Whoa!
Okay.
Anne told me...
All we really needed was to take the time to talk to each other.
Who wrote that?
Why that specific word?
Now...
I think I'm finally beginning to see what she meant.
I'd like to know what you think, Beelzebub.
Yeah, but why couldn't she say... kid?
No?
Because both you and Anne are the ones who achieved this end.
Why did they say it like that?
I don't care.
He said it sounds like a different word.
Whatever she wants.
And what do you think, Anne?
I want her...
to come with me.
Guys, remember, roommates...
they're just... very good friends.
You know how the saying goes...
Put water on an old fire...
but logs on a new one...
What the fuck does that mean?
What?
Okay,
this is not fair!
Like...
Okay, Rosetta has the same hair color as her dad.
But... and...
That's all I'm saying.
Because you guys are like, it's anime jeans, guys!
It's anime jeans!
Yeah, Santa exists in Sand Land.
Oh, here!
We're in...
Gar something.
I already forgot the ship's name.
What do you need the sand for?
Just take over somewhere else!
There's nothing here!
What?
But the Supreme Commander ordered us to the capital!
That can wait!
We're pounding the village into the ground first!
That TV really fucked him up.
If we show the Royal Army Garim in action, surely they'll realize how futile resistance is.
Imagine all the glass you commit, doki!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Very well.
Nothing wrong with saving the best for last.
Have their- the-the sandwich is so poor!
They're all so poor!
They just got watered!
Yes!
They got watered last week!
The Royal Army's gigantic battleship is floating over the dam!
Dammit!
So Garim's entered Sand Land.
Oh my, I just don't understand.
What's so great about Sand Land?!
Everybody wants to leave Settler!
We're not even technol- technological diff- Oh my gosh.
I'm sorry.
English is my first language.
We don't even have the technology!
They're more advanced than we are!
There's no way to know what a battle's outcome will be until it's fought.
You can use sad to make more TV.
Oh, Jenny, alright!
You're still alive!
Walk slower, please.
It's like fucking... civ.
It's like civilization.
We're like a civilization.
We're like the cavemen and they're like fucking making a nuclear bomb.
Alright, time to talk to the general.
Alright, alright.
They can build sad- They had- I don't know if you guys know this, but Forestland has a beach!
Oh, he was over in the cl- in the garage.
Okay.
I was like, where did he go?
What?
Don't be racist!
Move away!
That woman's a forced land army general!
Not anymore!
Rosetta's no longer our enemy!
I'm not sure.
What do you mean, I'm not sure?
At the moment, I don't have a plan behind it here, nor would I if I didn't.
Let me assure you.
For the time being.
My priority is...
stopping my father.
Do you really expect me to trust an enemy general?
Do you have like a fucking mini heart attack there?
There's no way that your wound could have healed yet.
Oh, that's why he was limping.
Who do you think wounded me?
Her brigade.
I know how you feel, but she's not mine.
I'm not sure, babe.
Prince should know.
Yeah.
Far as I can tell, he doesn't have any bad intentions.
Not so dead, Paul.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, that flick made her confused.
Give her a break.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is everybody injured?
Who's like not injured?
Where are you going?
I feel like I fought more and I'm okay.
I don't want to invite undue suspicion by making you worry I'm spying on your war council.
First, I'd like to hear everyone's thoughts.
Alright.
Chat with everyone.
You've fought the battle with that flying fortress long enough.
Their aquanium energy will have to run out at some point, right?
You mean like hundreds of thousands of years?
Because the aquaniums still work in those old wreckage.
That's true.
But how are we supposed to survive long enough for that to happen?
Yeah.
That's not a great idea.
Well...
Realize you hadn't really thought this through, huh?
Yeah, that's a terrible idea.
I was just taking my time thinking of the best strategy.
This is why we shouldn't have talked to everybody.
No.
Our only option is to attack so swiftly...
...that the enemy isn't given any time to think.
Yeah, they should have given her the Santa outfit.
Do you think Brad would be willing to talk if we could get Rosetta to contact him?
If he'd agree to a meeting, I'd speak with him in person.
Even if I had to go alone...
Okay, we're not going alone in an arm with an angel on their side.
If Brad were a man of reason, he would have listened to King Jam.
That's a fair point.
Maybe fighting is the only way.
I just hope we can settle this without getting civilians of either country involved.
Alright, apparently everybody had bad ideas.
So we should not listen to everybody.
What's that big people look?
Its main cannon is unimaginably powerful.
They could easily destroy the whole world if they wanted to.
To make things worse, it's too high up for our tanks to hit.
And even if they could, it's so massive that they wouldn't leave a dent.
The only options I can think of are to take control of the command center or somehow immobilize it.
Then how about we bust in there and kick their butts right now?
Wait, so the General had the only good idea because he's a General by the way, so he's used to making up- making plans.
Then why the fuck did we get in there?
We got input from you two!
He wanted to feel involved.
Doki.
This is a team effort.
We need an airplane fast enough to dodge anti-air missiles.
Come to think of it...
We'll have a plane?
How exactly did the forest land army transport that Aquanium from the In-Ville base?
Yeah.
What do you mean?
We used a radar device attuned to Aquanium to detect some at one of their bases.
And as we were watching, it then zoomed to a distant location at an incredible speed.
It might have been carried by an airplane.
They have airplanes?
It had to be.
It was moving in a straight line on the radar.
Yes.
Any form of ground transport would have been affected by the terrain.
Only an airplane could pull that off.
But where did it land?
Are we advanced enough?
We didn't see it there at the Masala dig site.
Rosetta would know.
Let me ask her.
Rosetta, are we advanced enough for planes?
Oh my god.
Rosetta, I want to drive a plane.
Why don't you look chipper?
That depends on your next answer.
Are you saying you want my help?
I won't ask you to fight.
I just want to know where the forest land army's airplane is.
It's one singular airplane.
The airplane?
The airplane.
Okay, we only have one.
You tell there's only one when they're like the airplane.
The airplane.
Not the airplanes.
Just one singular plane.
We have 500,000 tanks.
I'll do whatever it takes to stop bread.
I want to fly the airplane once we get it.
The Sunobi Zero airplane.
I want to fly it.
Now that you mention it, I've never gotten to pilot an airplane before.
Even the old man wants to give it a spin.
Oh no.
Guys, I think there might be zero planes soon.
No.
I'll do what I can to distract them from the ground with my tank unit.
In that case...
Yeah, but that's in Sand Land.
Even in Forest Land, there's one plane.
That's what I'm saying.
You have too many decoys, right?
The king might have outlawed planes in Sand Land.
But why does the Forest Land only have one?
I'm used to not having things easy.
Whoa.
No, you're supposed to be a Romain Rosetta.
Alright, let's see.
Yeah, this way.
We have to go to...
Alright, we have to go to... What the fuck?
How am I on the bike?
Okay, we gotta go to...
Back to Forest Land we go.
Alright.
Yeah, I found it.
How do we get up there?
Alright, I need to figure out how to get up.
I'm gonna assume it's this way.
Oh my god, how the fuck?
I assume it's like up like that.
Alright, it's time to get on the bike.
Alright.
If I go from here...
This should lead me to the mountain.
Right?
Yeah, it does.
Alright.
Wow!
Just one rock.
Alright, okay.
Just a rock.
Ooh!
There's loot.
No...
Alright.
Wait, there's bees?
Yeah.
Bees?
They have bees?
No, that's your dog.
Oh shit, sorry.
I'm shooting the wrong way.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, they do have bees!
I get honey from this!
Well...
I don't know about that.
Where's the queen?
Not the bees.
The bees!
Wait, but where's the queen then?
I don't see no queen.
Okay, we go this way.
Oh, that's the Omega Raptor.
Not as cool as the Alpha Raptors.
Is this this way?
I'm a little lost.
How do we get up there?
Uh...
Here?
Oh, there's more bees.
How do we get up though?
Uh...
Is there like a way up?
Oh no, there's loot though.
Alright, nice.
We got boosters.
I feel like it's definitely not from this way, so we're gonna drop down.
Uh...
Maybe from around here.
Maybe it's here?
Oh my god.
I'm lost!
I'm so lost!
How the fuck did you...
Oh my god.
Okay, clearly that wasn't...
Oh, I'm so lost.
High ground.
Uh...
What the fuck?
Not again!
Not again.
Wait, where...
Where...
What the hell?
Where did these guys come from?
Is it here?
Does this go up?
This has to go up.
I think it's here.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we did it.
We figured it out, guys.
We figured...
Oh!
A bush!
I...
Okay.
Alright.
The bush got me, chat.
The fucking bush got me.
Alright.
We're doing it.
The goddamn bush.
Alright, up we go.
Weeeee!
That one bush.
This bike managed to run past raptors and mechs.
Ah!
Except for that one mech.
Except...
No!
Are you serious?
I have to do that again!
Oh, my God.
I have to...
I have to do this again.
Are you serious?
I don't remember how I got there.
How the fuck...
Okay.
How did I get there?
Oh, okay.
Is this me?
Me.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe it.
I have to ride my bike all over again.
Some of you don't have the honey as well?
I think they took my honey too.
No!
I killed those bees for nothing!
Hey, there's a radio tower.
In a place like this, you can see it from far away.
Oh, okay.
I still want to extract.
We can use it as a landmark if we get lost.
Okay.
Not the honey.
All right.
You know what?
These don't really matter anyway.
I think it was like from here, right?
How do we...
How do we do this again?
I don't remember.
Oh, it's this way.
It's this way, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's from here.
All right.
They took my wife.
I can't believe it.
Got cucked by a honey bee.
Thick vegetation makes for easy ambushes.
I'm not sure if that's the right word.
All right.
Okay.
This time...
We're okay this time.
I'm not lost this time, guys.
I figured it out.
That's certainly something to keep in mind when in the jungle.
Okay.
I'm going to make sure I have my nitro boost.
My nitro boost ready.
Whoa.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
That's fine.
My bike is okay.
It's okay.
It's just a little injured.
He is...
He punched... See, that's what I was saying!
He literally punched my bike, but that does nothing!
Like, that's so bullshit!
He punched my bike, but I'm still on it!
But a bush!
The bush was our line.
Please no stealth, please.
Go ahead and sneak in if you're chicken.
I will.
Us guys are going through the front, right?
Cowards!
Pussies!
I don't need a sneak in!
I ain't no coward!
I have a tank!
Oh, they did it!
Oh wait, no, I did it.
I have a distraction!
I can do this!
The bug man!
There's more?
There's more!
Okay, please.
Please tell me I can summon my tank.
Oh, thank god.
Oh my god.
Alright, Hanta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
So here you are, poetry.
No, I'm not chicken!
That's different!
Okay, nice.
There's different types of birds!
No!
I don't want to go in there!
No, he kicked me off!
You're not allowed to drive!
Are you serious?
They did not see the tank!
They did not see the giant tank!
That's okay.
Alright.
They didn't see the giant fucking tank.
So now I have to do a stealth mission.
Okay.
Anybody here?
Can I cheese this?
They can't see me if I'm...
No!
They can look up!
Is that fair?
Why can't they look up?
Wait, where am I?
Oh, I made it here.
I got a checkpoint.
Okay, nice.
I got a checkpoint, guys.
No, I don't know where to go.
There's no yellow.
Here we go.
Okay, boom!
What do I do?
What do I do when there's no yellow?
I'm scared.
Oh.
What do I do?
There's no yellow anywhere!
Is he gonna turn around?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay.
Hehehehe.
I'm doing it my way.
Okay.
Whoa!
What the fuck?
How do I get across from there?
Wait, what?
Okay, I need to, like, figure this out, guys.
Oh, do I get through the poles?
No, that's not it.
Okay, now I'm a little lost.
Guys, why?
How do I get there?
Oh, I'm so scared.
I'm so scared.
There's so many people.
Oh, my God, there's so many people.
The tank can see me, too?
That should be illegal.
There's yellow paint there.
How do I get through that yellow paint?
Okay.
I'm gonna scare him.
Alright.
How do I scare the tank?
Guys, how do I scare the tank?
Ladder.
The ladder.
I see the ladder.
I'm improvising right now.
I don't know how to actually do this.
Oh.
Okay, we scare him.
And we climb.
We climb the ladder's yellow.
Now, how do I get across?
What the fuck?
I'm so confused.
How?
Wait.
There's an open window?
Oh!
That's how.
Okay, but like...
This is just loot.
That's just loot.
That's not...
That's not how!
That's just loot!
Oh, there!
It's over there!
It's at the back!
Okay, we got it.
We got it.
We don't need loot anymore, guys.
We don't need loot.
We're here for the plane!
This is enough loot for me.
You haven't even seen the plane before!
There's no plane to send then!
You got here first?
Slowpokes.
I got here before all of you, actually.
Wait, you got caught?
No, I was searching the cells and the door locked closed behind me.
Yeah, sure Ann.
Sheesh.
Talk about facial beauty.
Sure.
That's what they all say.
Thanks.
So, let me get this ready.
Okay.
How does she know how to fix planes?
She's never seen a plane before.
There's literally one plane!
Get on it.
Oh, Raul, get on the plane.
Oh my god, the insect men!
They let them integrate with the humans?
That's very like...
Because you gave us away with your yelling!
Shut up!
That's very progressive of them.
You already let the insect men integrate with the rest of the humans.
It's a tank with wings.
Hold on tight, everyone!
But demons...
Yeah, that's what I was gonna say.
Racist against demons, but not the insects.
That's what I was thinking too.
Hector, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
As someone who studied aviation maintenance, that airplane is a bit too chalky to be aerodynamically stable.
Those little wings can barely lift a damn thing.
Um, actually...
This is so exhilarating.
We have insect men right now, and you're here thinking, this plane should not be flying.
There's a little Death Star in the sky!
And you're worried about that?
This plane?
Hahahaha!
I mean, physics is physics.
Thank you, Hector.
Hahahaha!
Oh yeah, explain bees!
Oh yeah, we have rockets!
That's pretty good.
This guy's an angel.
Like, is there like, what, an angular angel?
Like, where are the other angels?
Where are the other angels that go?
Like, Muriel, it's time for bed!
Time's over!
Yeah,
where are the angels to spank this Brad?
General Array, heavy fire incoming!
What?
All troops, evacuate!
Sorry, traffic jam.
Hahaha!
We have a traffic jam!
Thank you for trusting your back to an enemy, General.
Oh!
Is he gonna die now?
What the?
Those suckers, they cannot see that.
Well, well.
Looks like someone is trying to play hero.
Supreme Commander!
Someone's there!
It's Rosetta!
What is she?
Abort!
Cease fire now!
It's too late!
We can't stop it from firing now!
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh, aim up!
Aim up!
Oh, that's awkward.
Where is he gonna hit now?
Oh!
Damn!
Fuck the animals that live there!
So it missed us.
That would suck if anyone lived there.
I knew that you would.
What were you?
He blew out the speedo.
Rest in please, Cliff Lass.
It's not over yet.
We need to keep the diversion going.
Beelzebub and the others should be en route to Garim as we speak.
Can we really be mad at that?
Our sensors are picking up something.
It's thermal signature.
It matches that of our own high speed plane!
Our one singular plane!
The resistance must have been the same.
We have hijacked it!
Quick!
Turn this thing around!
We're going to swat this fly!
We got spotted.
They'll shoot us full of holes in no time!
No shit, we got spotted?
Let's move altitude, Prince!
Maintain this altitude!
And get it as close as you can to Garim!
Oh, thank god.
I just have to go up and down.
Oh, this is easy.
Oh, wait, did I hurt myself?
Sorry.
This is easy.
Okay, now...
Now it's easy, guys.
Guys, this is harder than it looks!
But, oh shit!
But to me it looks easy.
To me it's easy, guys.
Just saying.
Weee!
What?!
Why was there a hole?
Okay!
There should not be a hole if I can't go through it.
Alright.
There we go.
This is on you guys for putting me on the wheel.
You did not have to give me the wheel.
Oh.
Do I have guns?
How?
Whoa!
Just go...
Just go up and down.
That's how.
This is how you dodge.
Easy.
Wait!
That's more than one plane!
I thought they had one singular plane!
There's more?!
Alright.
It lied to me.
That's it.
Right ahead.
Came straight for Gaara.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
There was more than one plane!
What the fuck is this?
What the fuck?!
How?!
Oh no!
No!
I did it!
It's Toho.
No!
Toho!
My one weakness!
Not Toho.
Oh god.
Oh, this is awkward.
No, not more trouble!
I can't see!
No, that one hit!
Oh my god, that's so bullshit!
I literally won it!
No I can do this all over again!
Okay guys, this time... I can figure this out.
Oh god, guys, I can figure this out.
Guys, see, I can do Touhou.
I can do Touhou.
I get 10 tries!
Okay.
Alright.
No!
Okay, 8 tries!
8 tries!
8 tries, guys!
Okay, I think this is stereo.
We did it.
Insert credit.
Wait, what do I... what do I do?
What do I... what do I do?
What?
Oh, I did it.
I could... what?
I barely registered what I was supposed to do.
I didn't even know what I did.
Oh, okay.
Goodbye, singular plane.
That wasn't the only plane, apparently.
I accidentally did the QuickTime events.
I don't know how.
I thought we were dead.
Madame Adon, prep me for this.
And how are we supposed to get off this contraption without a plane?
It's a whole flying fortress.
Surely there's some escape pods.
Basically.
We'll figure it all out later, don't worry.
So, let's get wrecked!
Goodbye, last plane.
The last plane in this army.
Hey!
What are you doing?
I'll handle this traitor myself.
I trust you have no objections.
Whoa.
That was close.
Hey, we gotta find the commander center.
It ends here.
Alright, we got this.
I believe in us, guys.
This is it.
Now!
Now, we're at the final part, guys.
This is it.
I know I said that an hour ago.
And two hours ago.
But this time!
This is the final area.
For real.
This has to be the final area.
Now, we're at the final stage.
This is it.
For real.
For real, guys.
This has to be the final area.
Okay.
What?
I didn't hit that?
He, like, tanked it.
Holy shit.
That takes so much.
Come on, just let me shoot you once.
There you go.
Trust.
The final part.
Part 3.
Oh, god.
Tank is blocking.
Here you go.
Holy shit, that's a lot of mechas.
But can't we only have, like, one plane?
Jesus.
Yeah.
Whoa!
Don't worry, I got you.
I'm gonna shoot through this hole.
Did I do it?
I did it.
Yeah!
No, the bridge!
Where'd I fucking go?
Oh, do I have to go this way?
No, it's 2D time.
That's a lot of people.
Holy shit.
It breaks that, but not the other bridge?
Alright, it's time.
That's fucking right.
You think I'm scared?
I will bring this tank up there.
I'm gonna bring this tank up there!
That's fucking right!
You think stairs is gonna fucking stop me?
I'm gonna bring this tank up there!
That's right.
Stairs are not gonna stop me!
I'll walk up the stairs and bring my tank over.
Wait, what's this?
This is yellow.
Loot.
Alright.
Sorry, I got sidetracked by loot.
Oh, shit!
Forest land officer.
Who brings a tank?
I bring a tank!
Whoa!
This guy brought a tank too!
Oh, shit!
He hit me!
I'm flipping!
Run!
Nice.
Okay, that's good.
Yeah, beat up the old man.
Don't beat up me.
Nice.
We have distraction.
Oh, wait!
I can do this!
Nice!
Nice, we did it.
Nice.
We did it.
Yeah!
Alright.
Now where do we go?
Oh, this way.
Where am I supposed to shoot?
Oh, this has to be foreshadowing.
Cause like, where am I supposed to shoot for this?
That's a foreshadow for something, I'm pretty sure.
I must have to do that late at another time.
Woo!
It's okay I can run faster.
What do you mean, I have to place?!
No!
Oh my God!
I have to use my head?
I can't believe it!
I can't bring a tank!
That's so fucked up.
It wouldn't let me bring a tank to the fight.
What?
Oh.
Wait.
What?
Where am I supposed to go then?
Am I supposed to beat you up first?
Oh no!
It's okay.
Uh... Oh I have to press a button!
Alright, that makes a lot more sense.
Actually makes a lot of sense now.
This way.
Oh my god!
He's me!
He knows!
Wait.
What?
Then what?
Ready button mash.
Huh?
Did I not...
Did I not do it?
Oh!
There's more than one!
Did I do it?
I did it!
I figured it out!
Button mashing time!
No!
Guys.
It's okay.
There's a water bottle at the next stop.
I believe...
I can make it.
Oh there's loot too.
Nice.
Wait.
But where does this go?
Oh.
This is where we're supposed to go.
I didn't realize that door is locked.
Anyway.
This is where we're supposed to go.
Oh.
Gosh.
Oh shit!
No!
I can't drink water!
Woo!
No!
Okay.
I have to use my arms.
Alright.
I used my arms.
Oh!
Thank God!
Water!
Oh!
This is right in the world!
I knew it!
I knew the backside would have loot!
I could feel it!
Oh my!
Now I can bring my tank!
That's right!
You guys thought it's over!
You guys thought you couldn't get over here!
I brought the tank back.
Oh!
I'm outside again?
Is this it?
Is this what it's for?
Wait!
You brought me off the thing!
No!
Get over here!
Oh my God!
Stop!
He's walking back!
He's floating backwards so slow!
It's messing me up!
Nice!
My 3 XP!
That's what I'm talking about!
That's what I needed!
Is the aquarium causing this?
Okay.
Such a powerful energy source!
It could do so much good!
Put to better uses!
Oh my gosh!
One down!
We could have all the electricity and power in the world!
Is it here?
Oh!
Just fall straight down?
Ah!
Okay!
Alright!
I'm okay!
At least it being 2D!
I'm not going to die!
2D!
It's easier to destroy these bots!
Alright!
Nice!
There's so much electricity!
Electricity fields here!
Goodbye!
Oh!
I almost...
I thought I couldn't get that!
Alright!
Down I go!
Yay!
Ooh!
Tank time!
Alright!
What the fuck?
Are these guys trying to do something?
This is not your fight!
Oh!
Fuck!
Okay!
Uh...
Did I do it?
Did I hit them?
I did.
Okay.
Nice!
Get away!
This is not your fight!
Leave!
This is a tank fight!
You're not a tank!
Alright!
Down I go!
God!
There's so much protection!
Looks like I can get on and keep going!
Okay.
Alright!
And off we go!
Loot!
Yay!
Loot that I'm not gonna use because we're finally at the final part of the game!
There's no point in getting loot!
Post...
You guys know I'm not gonna do post-game, right?
But don't you think about the post-game!
The post-what?
A game that's finished when a game hits the credits!
Tanks?
Here we go!
They're coming after us with everything they've got!
Okay, we gotta make sure we repair!
We must be getting close!
Alright, nice!
Alright...
Oh, that's the officer!
Okay.
Oh, shit!
Oh my god!
What the fuck!
Oh, shit!
Holy shit!
That guy does so much damage!
Okay, okay.
We're just gonna do this!
Don't you think about the post-game loot!
Thank you for the Akasufa!
Thank you!
Jesus Christ!
That tank did so much damage!
Holy shit!
Goodbye, officer.
Oh, this way.
Oh, okay.
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit!
Thank you Super Chat!
Thank you!
Oh my god!
The tiny insect men!
Okay, after giving me tanks to fight, they're gonna send these guys over?
That's just...
How much damage are you gonna do?
Yeah, I thought so.
That's embarrassing.
That's embarrassing there.
There you go.
I'm gonna go this way.
It's like Ashley swatting flies.
Oh my god.
You know what?
I know you're just chilling, but like, fuck you too.
He's like, what did I do?
I was just taking in the scenery.
Any more?
No more?
Yeah.
I thought so.
Oh!
Wait!
That's you!
Dragon Ball Bot!
Not fast enough though.
Couldn't use your knife.
That's fucking right.
Is there another one?
Oh shit, there was.
Wait, he's level 24.
That's not fair.
I can only be level 20 because it's...
Post game shit.
There you go.
The 9 XP.
He's literally higher level than me and I still get 9 XP.
He brought a knife to a tank, but I know right.
That was easy.
Okay.
Is it working?
Is this working?
Is there supposed to be like a switch?
Oh!
No, there's loot.
Okay, let me grab the loot first.
That I definitely don't need.
How do I ride the elevator?
Elevator up?
Oh, okay.
I have to press Y.
That tiny little button there that told me to press Y.
Oh, we're almost there.
Twenty.
Ten.
Oh shit!
Okay.
Oh!
Fucking what the fuck!
Oh my god!
Guys, he's putting me in the corner!
He's putting me in the corner!
Oh!
Fuck!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, it was like a gang fight!
Like what the...
Holy shit, that was...
Oh my god, that was...
Oh my god!
Get me out of here!
Oh!
Holy shit!
That was actually crazy!
How the fuck was that legal?
Oh my god.
That did not feel legal at all.
He actually like stuffed me into the corner of the room.
I've gotta be fucking mad.
We can't lose this fight.
Let's make sure that we're prepared.
Alright.
I think we're prepared.
I think that's really all.
I'm gonna wait until I get 100% guys on the laser.
I'm like 20... I'm gonna wait until I get 100% on the laser.
Gonna eat my sandwich.
Deadpool, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Bravestor Doki ran away.
She bravely ran away.
When danger reared its ugly head, she bravely turned her tail and...
It's not running away!
It's called tactical retreat!
People do it!
It's tactical!
Okay, I took a bite out of my sandwich.
I'm ready.
Okay.
Okay, let's see.
Reload, reload.
We're ready.
What the fuck?
Which one is it?
Oh, it's this guy again!
It's him!
Okay.
Okay, we can do this.
I... I...
Okay!
I realized lasers don't work!
I am...
I figured out lasers do not work on this guy!
Guys, it was close!
Guys, it was so close though!
It was so close!
Guys, it was bare... We almost hit it!
Jesus, how am I... Oh my god, I'm gonna fucking...
Trying to get rid of all of these first.
Holy shit!
Okay.
Oh yeah, I totally got this guy!
I totally do!
Okay, I'm just gonna use the explosive lasers...
On like... on like the things around me.
I feel like...
Okay, how did I miss?
Okay.
I'm gonna use it on these guys though.
Woo!
Do I?
Okay, fuck you guys though!
You guys... you guys need to...
You guys need to leave.
You guys actually need to leave.
Oh god.
Run!
Do your thing, run!
God, he's so tanky!
Oh, he's almost down!
He's almost down!
No!
It's fine, it's just...
It's just...
Oh, it's not fine!
Guys, it's not fine.
Oh, why am I...
Oh god, why did I drop down?
Why did I drop down?
No!
Oh god.
Bro, he's fucking pushing me down!
Nice, BL, keep going!
This is not fair.
This is actually not fair.
Get this guy away from me.
Get this guy away from me!
Okay.
Alright, we're okay, we're okay, we're okay.
Keep on the offensive!
Oh no!
I don't feel so good!
Shit!
Wait, wait!
This should work!
This should work now!
Because we're here!
I st...
cry I still don't touch it!
How do I not touch it?!
I don't understand how do I not touch it?
Holy shit!
This is not fair!
Okay, this is actually not fair.
Where is he?
One more hit!
No!
Step one more hit!
Oh, thank god it's over!
Oh, it's over!
It's over!
Okay, we gotta like fix some...
We gotta make sure we have enough repair kits here.
Alright, repair kit max.
Okay, we're gonna put that here.
Oh, we did it.
We fucking did it.
I got him!
Down the elevator I go!
Can't believe it, our lasers hit.
It didn't work!
I can't believe our laser didn't work.
Okay, loot that I don't...
Oh, repair kit, nice!
Oh, thank god!
We needed the repair kit.
Oh, and water!
We always need water!
Okay, apparently not now though.
Nice!
Fill up that water!
This looks like final boss area-ish.
Red?
I wasn't sure you'd make it here.
You getting the jitters now?
Do I look scared?
Guess not.
I was like, you didn't quick travel the sock up for- Oh, nevermind.
Red!
Okay, he's not final boss cause we have to fight Muriel.
Don't bother him.
He's like second final boss.
But, I made a promise to Rosetta!
He's not gonna have a change of heart.
Gotta strike him down.
It seems you understand me well.
I don't need to.
You can't change him!
He grew up in the old times!
Where people hated fiends!
It must be because I lost him long ago.
What?
Nothing matters!
Nothing matters to me anymore.
Nothing!
Except my country, Forestland.
And I swear, I will exterminate any threat!
Oh shit!
Be it Sandland or Fiendkind!
Oh my god, he doesn't have a heart!
Wait!
Wait a minute!
Okay, thank god!
I was gonna say- Oh, this is bad!
Hahahahaha!
I was gonna say, it's bad that- like...
OH MY GOD!
I was gonna say this is awkward- if it was the mech fight because we did not upgrade the mech.
We...
We- OH SHIT!
WE SHOULD HAVE UPGRADED THE MECH!
We should've upgraded the mech, guys!
Guys, I would bring the mech out if the mech had any upgrades.
But unfortunately, I put all in on the tank.
I went all in.
I went all in, guys.
It's fine.
We just need to wait until... Holy shit.
Oh my god.
I am trying my best, thief!
Okay.
We have nitro.
We have to reload though.
Woo!
Honestly, yeah.
You should.
I'm actually doing really well.
Okay, he missed.
Nice.
No.
Okay.
No!
It's actually not fair.
He just jumped.
This is not a jump, boy!
Oh.
Oh my god.
He can jump.
That's so messed up.
He can do a lot apparently.
Oh my god.
He's almost done.
Okay.
We're so close.
No!
I can't get away from that!
Okay.
We're fine.
So we don't need to use it yet.
Alright.
Several more hits left.
Woo!
What the fuck!
No, no, no, no, no!
I was so close!
That was so close!
That was actually so close!
Oh, I would have been...
Oh my god!
Oh no!
He's nearly won!
Oh my god!
That did like more than 50%!
Why?
I turned my heart to stone and shattered it to pieces all for my...
You have no heart?
How are you alive?
How cruel.
That now even my body will be smashed apart by this accursed fiend.
No.
Perhaps losing everything is exactly what I...
Nano Machines.
Can you stop with the pity party?
Fred, how exactly do you think we even made it this far?
It was Rosetta.
She told us where the airplane was.
So she betrayed military secrets to the enemy.
She was deeply conflicted over it.
But the reason she ultimately did it...
Was to stop you.
She wanted to save you from the self-destructive spiral.
That's what you call...
Standing in the way of Garum's cannon.
To protect the enemy.
Yeah, but you didn't kill her.
So you still have a heart.
That's what treachery... what is.
It was you she wanted to protect.
Not the Royal Army.
She was trying to stop you.
She wanted to save your soul.
She staked her life on it.
You're saying she...
That's what I choose to believe at least.
I can't claim to truly know the heart of another person.
Reading minds is fiends territory after all.
I know that Rosetta has so much she wants to tell you.
So please stop your war crimes.
But after all I've done...
How can I possibly face her now?
I mean you're both murderers.
It's not like one...
Like maybe one has killed more than the other.
But you still all killed civilians.
As her father.
So you're like on the equal... I guess you guys are equal.
Aren't there things you want to tell your father too, Chris?
Flick him.
War crime, please.
Just flick him, you're right.
Just flick him.
Let's go beat that angel and get this over with.
How is she doing?
The thing I'm very surprised by is that we forgive these two very easily for...
Like yes, they're now on our side.
But like...
They still murdered?
Like...
I'm pretty sure the wives...
that have told about how their husbands were great heroes will not appreciate that.
Surely a fiend is in no position to judge me for that.
Anime logic.
With the power of anime!
You shall be absolved of the thousands of people you murdered.
Because you're hot.
As long as you look good doing it.
Yeah, I mean we forgave Vegeta.
Very easily.
Because with the Dragon Balls we can wish them back to life.
So commit as much murder as you want!
We'll just wish them back to life!
Alright, let's see...
But Vegeta's a homie!
That's different, Doki.
He's a homie.
Alright, let's see...
Alright, it's time.
It's time, Muriel.
Are you...
Put your jacket up!
What the fuck, Muriel!
Put a shirt!
It's cold!
Are those chicken wings?
What the fuck is that?
You put a shirt on!
Now it's not just about it being cold!
Now it's not just about you putting a shirt on!
Or rather it was.
Until the humans defiled it!
What the fuck is wrong with your back?
They fell further and further from grace.
Oh, he's a falling angel!
It is us angels duty to bring the humans back to the light.
And vanquish the demons responsible for...
I don't feel comfortable.
Hey!
I'm in the middle of a speech here!
Orange, welcome to Tomato...
I'm so concerned that you chose the chicken wings moment.
I just didn't fucking join the membership for welcome.
I shouldn't have expected any better from a fiend.
Lucifer was exactly the same.
He wouldn't listen to a single word.
Just tore off my beautiful wings as I begged him not to!
Oh, he did that!
I'm not surprised a rotten apple like this...
But I'm not surprised a rotten apple like you hasn't fallen far from the tree.
Like I care.
Enough talking.
Let's rumble!
You wanna fight?
You've got one.
Let's settle this with just our sticks.
Nooo!
Round three!
Time to see which one of us is stronger, one team for all!
You impudent brat!
I'll teach you just how much stronger angels are than fiends!
Just please let me get the cake!
Please!
This time for real!
NOOOOOO!
Bro, get over here!
Get over here!
Okay, let me... I bought strength serum for this.
I had a feeling I'm gonna have to do this.
Okay, and then health drink.
Alright, health drink will be here.
Uhh...
Health... Wait, that...
Wait, did I put the health drink on?
No, I didn't.
Put that here.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
Alright, now I'm strong!
Oh shit.
Get over here!
Now I'm strong!
I'm gonna beat the shit out of you!
Child!
Get your chicken nugget wings in here!
Oh shit.
I didn't see that.
That's not fair.
Here we go.
That's right.
Say that again to my face!
I ate some spinach!
That's fucking right, Mutia!
I got some spinach in my ass!
Oh my god, bubble!
Oh shit.
No, not the bubble!
Not the bubble!
Oh shit!
You can't turn around fast enough.
You're on a roller.
I learned, guys.
Look at yourself.
You're supposed to put in your first Oh shit.
mouth.
It's like...
Things end up... if you guys don't know, if you put things in the butt, it absorbs fasting.
If you guys didn't know about that...
I hate you.
You're the best, Bubba.
But you are indeed strong.
Thing is...
What?
Is he absorbing the equilibrium?
Oh my god!
He's oo-ing!
He's oo-ing out!
His oo-power!
Oo-woo.
Oo-woo overdrive!
Who's that in the bathroom?
That's right.
What the fuck?
Holy shit!
He has wings now!
Okay, but how do you know that?
I think it was super chat.
Alright, thank you, thank you.
Jesus Christ.
Thank fucking God!
Oh my God, thank you!
Whoa!
I was... what?
Jesus Christ!
Okay, wait.
There we go.
Yeah.
Yeah!
What?
Okay.
I didn't realize I did that little damage.
Oh, he's on me!
He's on me!
He's looking at me!
Oh!
I gotta repair just in case!
Okay, nice.
Thank God.
I can finally use my main power!
I do like... okay, 2000.
That's good.
What do you mean, this won't do?
I am trying my best!
I'm doing little poke damage right now!
What is his weakness?
Is it his butt?
Okay, nice.
Charging as max as I can!
Okay, 3000.
Yeah, no shit.
You're not losing your nerve, are you?
What the fuck?
What the fuck?!
How did he get bigger?
Holy shit!
Oh my God, bro!
Someone stop beating him!
Who keeps beating this giant?!
Who keeps beating him?!
Oh God.
Someone... someone needs to stop.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
We got him.
He's down.
He's down, guys!
He's down!
Oh no!
He can't get up!
He can't!
He's stuck!
Oh, thank God he's stuck.
Is he bugged?
Is he actually bugged?
Oh my God, damn it!
What?!
So easy!
The hardest boss fight of my life.
Wait, no!
He bugged himself!
No!
Oh my God, what the fuck?!
He turned back!
How did he do it?!
Holy shit, he turned back!
Oh God.
Maybe I should have been up, but...
Maybe that would work.
Okay.
Is he transforming again?
Oh God, I'm gonna...
Uh... Max.
Okay, I'm gonna do this.
Oh, he's back!
He's back!
He's big boy again!
He's big boy!
Okay.
This is gonna take a couple of years.
Oh my God!
Is he bigger?!
Oh, he fell again!
He can't get up!
This is it!
Oh shit.
This is not fair.
Oh my God, no.
He's gonna go back.
Oh... Oh no!
No!
Oh, he's back!
I'm not fast enough!
Jesus Christ, he's so tanky!
Just shoot him in the dick!
Alright.
That's everybody's weakness!
It doesn't matter if you're an angel!
Oh no.
Okay.
Bam.
Alright.
Guys, we're almost there.
I can feel it!
No!
We've made it so far!
Ral, get in there!
What?!
How did he sidestep again?!
How does he keep...
How does he keep sidestepping?!
I'm so unlucky.
I'm actually so unlucky.
He actually sidestepped.
Oh my God.
He's so close.
This is it.
He's setting in!
He's getting tight!
He's getting eepy!
He's getting eepy, guys!
Oh God.
Oh, I didn't get further away though.
I didn't get further away though.
Woo!
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, one hit!
One more hit!
Quadruple hit!
Last hit here!
This has to be it!
Yes!
This should be it!
This should be now phase three!
Did I do it?
Yes!
Are you okay?
Oh!
Even the angels are in the army.
Do you truly believe that what you are doing is right?
Where's the other angels?
The divine one is perfect.
And as his child, so am I.
Obviously, it is not even possible for me to do wrong.
But doesn't God say thou shalt not dope up?
Is that in the commandments?
It's up to me, Lulia, to guide you back to the...
Hey, right with wings.
Oh!
Oh, I'm powerful!
Oh my God!
My shirt!
My cape!
Said your prayers yet?
Whoa.
Badass!
Like...
I'd let...
an angel...
be more evil!
Oh my god, can we still go?
Oh, Jen's built the urn!
Jen threw it up!
What the fuck?
When's Lilith?
Mom!
Sister!
Wait, if the urn falls and it cracks then it frees them.
Mom's alive!
She's alive!
Is this timed?
I hope it's not timed.
Cause I need a fixed chat.
Are we gonna save chicken wings?
I can't believe it, we're saving chicken wings.
You can tell he wants to save him.
We didn't save Epi, but we saved chicken wings?
He's changing his heart.
Sinners don't do a Queenie.
Thank you for the super chat, Kaz.
Thank you, thank you.
That's what happens in war!
Jesus, he's used his cyborg strength for that.
Not before our eyes!
We're ascending too fast now.
It's no use!
I've lost all control over it!
The Equadium's gonna explode any moment now!
Abandon ship!
There's nothing else we can do!
Use the escape pods by the command center!
Go on, now!
Supreme Commander!
We've been waiting!
Is he... Is he seeing pods?
Oh, so I need to tap buttons.
I need to reload my chat real fast.
It's the same pods!
These are... Yeah, that's us!
Soldier, get out!
Goodbye, soldier!
Sorry, ma'am, but that's a safety pass.
There's five main characters.
I don't know what his problem is.
There's one guy with no name.
Don't worry.
I'm feed.
I'm afraid I can't allow that.
If anyone should stay...
Everyone that has a name, get in the Saiyan pod!
I'll start with this.
I'll stay and see it through to the end.
Quit brooding and get in the pod!
Where's the soldier?
There's only three people there!
Don't trust the word of a fiend!
I do.
More than anything.
They're at the back!
Am I gonna save chicken wings?
Wings?
Oh!
I am!
It's okay, just drink your serum!
Oh my god, this sucks because I'm actually just limping.
I can't even walk faster.
Alright, chicken wings.
Time to pull you up!
Why?
Why do we need to save Munya?
He already sinned!
Just use your heals, bro!
I spent so much money!
Why are you here?
Where's bread?
We made it this far together.
Why would we separate now?
So only the soldier took the pod?
I said that.
I mean I appreciate it.
Yeah, how are we gonna get down?
How are we gonna get down?
You can take us.
Can't you just fly us all down there?
With four people?
It might work with just chicken wings and not the carry-on.
Poor Myra people!
Oh man, that was a poor planning.
Yeah, what do we do?
Anne?
What's this?
Oh!
It's a little candy!
Damn, 10 whole seconds?
Woah!
Okay...
That's a lot of faith.
Just drop down until 10 seconds.
You know if you're too high up?
You won't even die before you hit the floor.
You literally die from a heart attack because of the pressure.
Before you hit the floor.
Before you die from the death of the floor.
So all I'm saying is that like...
Scientifically, that's not how it should work.
Well, there she goes!
That's very fast.
Or like, yeah, lack of oxygen.
Beef, your turn!
Guys, I have a bucket of water!
Mythbusters sad land!
Oh, hurry up!
It's like... It's like Bureau Clock all over again.
Here we go!
Oh no!
It's okay, I'm a fiend.
I don't get heart attacks from this guy.
What the fuck is the ga- I guess- Wait, but they don't have goggles.
I've only got one floaty tablet left?
Did you not count?
Hold on.
He can't swallow one while he's knocked out.
Well, okay.
Guess I gotta take care of this- The others don't have goggles?
What the fuck?
Is it- Did that help me?
Dad?
Dad!
Were you able to get out of the jar on your own?
No.
As luck would have it, the urn smashed against a rock.
The bra!
You saved me from a rough landing.
Oh, that was me.
Sister!
You're pink!
I knew it!
Whoa!
That- Whoa!
That help- Whoa!
Whoa!
Prince!
You had us worried you were up there for so long!
You all made it safely!
I told you the tablets would work!
Those things didn't help us at all!
Even the timing rat is impossible!
We all chickened out and took the tablets too soon!
So they wore off when we were still high up!
But before we crashed, some strange power saved us!
It looks like your family actually came to our rescue.
Ah!
Saved me too!
How come the sister doesn't have a tail?
Mom!
You must be... my mom?
She'd never seen her mom before?
I thought Moni El killed you!
Like, she's the same person, just pink!
There were two urns of sealing.
I was in the other.
You really think some second-rate angel could have defeated me without one of those?
Oh...
I see.
Aww!
Ma'am, you've grown up so much.
Please, stop that!
My father?
He's fine.
Thank goodness.
So this... is your daughter, Lilith?
I guess we're all just a king chat now!
Well then, thank you Super Chat!
Thank you!
Never refer to me by this undignified form of address again!
I am Lucifer!
The King of Demons!
What the f*** was she gonna say to you?!
Your Majesty?
Oh...
But you're a princess too!
That?
Oh no, that's bread.
Nevermind.
Queen Lilith.
And Princess Anne!
I deeply regret what I did ten years ago.
I was wrong about fiends.
Yeah.
Speak to all those wives that lost their husbands!
And all those children that lost their fathers!
Yeah!
Get those tree-huggers!
Yeah, what shall we do with chicken wings?
I'll take care of it then.
Serves him right.
Rain?
In sunlight?
Guys!
You see this?
It's raining!
Well, I'll be!
How's it rain?
It's the Aquanium at work.
The Aquanium?
It took 30 years, but it's being used as the Pichi intended.
Finally.
By the way, human.
What was your name again?
Oh!
Welcome to Mudland.
No, not what's said!
Treasure chest.
Huh?
Dad!
I was wondering if I can play games for two hours a day now.
Maybe?
Don't push your luck.
Practicing your flying would be a far better use of your time.
Right!
I thought you said you're going to fly!
Yay!
We did it!
Oh my god!
It is...
That's when you win!
You know we beat the game when the rainbow comes on the screen.
Is there after credits?
Thank you Toriyama-san.
Oh my god!
Is there an after credits, guys?
Ooh!
There's screenshots.
There is?
Okay, I'll wait until after credits.
Oh my god!
We finally did it!
Chat!
Dragos!
We beat our first JRPG!
Oh!
I'm so proud of us.
We stuck it through.
It took us a lot, a lot of time.
But it took us all the way until I got a new skin suit.
And we finally beat it!
Oh!
What a wild ride that was.
That was great though.
I had a great time.
My very first JRPG that I've ever finished.
Potter, thank you for the 20 gifted ships!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
But like, honestly, I had a great time.
I really did.
I know some of the dungeons were a little bit slow, like a bit repetitive.
But I really did enjoy playing this game with all you guys.
And like, you know, getting to connect with Bandai too because of Sandland.
It was such a great opportunity.
And I'm really happy to be actually able to finish it for you guys.
I've never, like I said, I've never finished a JRPG before.
But this is like a mixture of action.
So like, it made me be able to play it actually.
Like I wasn't as, like, I used to get really bored with JRPGs in general.
Because like, I don't really like the fighting mechanics for JRPGs.
Because it's just a preference for me.
So I'm really happy that like, you know, I like the action in this.
And I really like the action mechanics within this in Sandland.
So it really did make it very much more playable for me.
And...
It was...
Take it to the end!
Um...
But yeah, I really like the animation in the 3D models too.
I liked how the 3D models really emphasized Toriyama-san's art style.
And how it was very well modeled and very well animated for 3D.
Because it looks 2D for a 3D model.
Which is like such an accomplishment to do in general.
Uh...
And...
That's all I want to say.
But I'm so happy to finish this game with you guys and get to the ending!
Oh my god!
Fucking Chiku...
Oh my gosh.
I wish he put on a shirt.
I wish!
If only he...
I did not want to see him without the shirt.
I really did not like it when he took off his shirt, man.
It was...
It was very uncomfortable.
Yeah...
The chicken wings are very curt .
They really were .
But yeah!
Oh...
I don't know if I can just skip the credits.
So am just gonna wait until it plays to the end.
It's been alright.
It's been a wild wild ride today.
A wild ride in the tank...
That's for sure.
I'm gonna stretch!
Yeah...
Oh yeah!
I heard First Descendant came out today.
Or was it yesterday?
How is it?
You think it's worth playing?
People said it's basically Korean... it's a Korean developer, right?
Korean publishing?
It's basically Destiny, but like... Destiny 2, but...
But like made by Korean developers.
Yeah, because I heard it was like Nexon.
But I saw people were trying to play it because they're like...
Since it's like similar to Warframe slash Destiny 2.
I know it just came out today.
I don't know.
Free to play?
Okay.
It says free to play, but you know damn well like later...
There's a system in place in there.
That justifies the free to play.
Yeah.
Quote on quote on the free.
It has mixed reviews.
I guess I won't try it out then.
I was like thinking if I should try out the First Descendant next week.
But if it has mixed reviews, then I won't check it out.
Yeah, the microtransactions and stuff.
I know that's what I was thinking.
I was like wondering if I should try it out.
Because people were like yeah, it's the next game that's coming out.
Next big game that's coming out.
To be fair, a lot of AAA games.
I mean, I feel like Nexon is considered AAA publisher.
Because they have made a lot of big games too.
But and that blind girl, Raine Bland forever.
Oh yeah, we never cured her.
Oh yeah!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We never cured.
We never cured the blind girl.
We killed the alpha raptor.
But we never came back to cure her.
Oops.
That's my bad.
Oh yeah, the whole Dark and Darker thing that happened.
Yeah, I didn't end up playing Dark and Darker.
Because when it came out, a lot of people gave mixed reviews about it.
Because apparently, even though it was like free to play back on Steam.
The updates for it was not great.
I don't know they fixed it.
I was like thinking about it.
But then I read the reviews and people were like it's not.
It says free to play but you have to pay.
Because you don't keep your loot.
You don't keep your loot if you're playing the free version.
You have to pay to keep the loot or something.
Or like to unlock stuff.
That's why people were like yeah, it's free but it's bait.
That's why I never checked it out.
Because I know when I was like oh it's free to play.
I might try it next week.
But then I read the reviews and people were like...
People were like oh yeah, it's bait.
Like if you actually really want to unlock more of the game.
You have to pay money for it.
Because like if you play the free version.
You don't keep your loot at all after a run.
Something like that.
Yeah.
Yeah, you get the...
I mean obviously.
I mean that's the whole mechanic.
You get the loot if you can get out.
But like...
And you have to pay to have another character.
Yeah, I saw that too.
I saw that you have to pay to get another character.
I just saw a lot of like...
A lot of like complaints about it.
Because it went from positive reviews when it came out.
To like negative.
To like I don't know if it has negative or mixed right now.
But I saw that it went from positive.
Because everyone was like yay it's back on Steam.
And then straight to negative after like one day.
And I was like reading some of the reviews.
I was like what the f*** happened?
The people were happy.
And then...
And I...
Now I don't know.
I don't know if it's mixed now.
Or like if it's still negative.
You just buy if you don't...
If you like...
It's just like people...
The thing is people don't like to be like baited.
You know?
If it's gonna be free.
Because when they dropped it on Steam.
They made it like it's free now.
So it baited a lot of people.
And people hate getting baited.
You know?
People hate it.
Because they feel like they got like you know.
They got like scam type deal.
Like you know it's free.
But like oh you baited me into this.
So people were mad.
Because they're like just call it a demo then.
Don't say it's free to play.
Just call it a demo instead of free to play.
Because in the end all the actual...
All the actual like game mechanics is locked behind a paywall.
So people got really mad about it.
Or a free trial.
So that's why it got review bombed.
Because everyone...
Because like when they released they announced Dark and Darker being back on Steam.
During the Summerfest or whatever.
During the Summer Game Fest.
They just said it's back on Steam.
And it's free to play.
They never said anything about it.
They never said anything about it being locked behind.
Like have like certain mechanics being locked behind paywall.
So everyone was like this is fucked up.
And people hate getting baited.
Yeah.
If anything people are very passionate when they get misled.
It's mostly positive.
Now that's good to know.
I think they might have like also...
Apparently updated the game to...
They updated the game to like...
To appease people.
Because I saw Surefour playing Dark and Darker earlier too.
Because at first he was like...
Nah I'm not gonna play it yet.
Because apparently he's like...
Nah it's not that great yet.
So if he's playing it again I assume that they updated it.
And so Rain fell on Sandland for the first time in decades.
Bringing with it many changes.
Oh hey.
Grass now.
She's not pink anymore!
Why are you ashamed of being pink?!
Nice.
No!
It's sad!
Hahaha!
Harry can fine -tuned Rosetta with repairing the rift between humans and demons to prevent further misunderstandings.
Ha ha ha ha!
Drop em!
He destroyed our home.
The angels!
Yeah!
Hahaha!
That's so fucked up!
Why don't they give him his wings back?
That's bad!
Oh my god, it's a Dragon Ball card!
He's working for Amazon now.
Into the Bezo mines you go!
It's time for the Amazon warehouses!
The world is not just sad then.
What?
Oh no!
Not the car!
Yeah!
Wait, Bells is me.
What did you do, Drago?
He's just like me!
For real, for real!
You guys are thief and I'm Bezo-bob.
Gonna need to take it to the garage in Spino to get it fixed up.
Yeah!
Spino is our next stop!
Hmm.
I'll come with you.
What about seeing the world?
Oh.
It's not like I'm in a hurry.
Pretty sure hanging around you guys will give my skills a better workout than seeing the world could.
What?
They're literally just going to the Peachy!
And it's settled!
It's road trip time!
Yeah!
Stay in Sandland!
Let's go!
Back to Spino!
You never leave Spino!
We did it!
We finished the game!
Yippee!
I'm so proud of us.
We fucking did it, guys!
We finally beat Sandland!
Alright, let's go back to...
Oh my gosh.
Whoops.
Sorry, chat broken.
Oops.
I forgot to post a chat here too.
Oh!
Whatever.
I'm gonna save the game.
Even though I never touched the game back after completing it, I still feel like I have to save it.
Oh hell, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
You finished Sandland while I was at work?
Do over at 2 minute do over.
Start from the beginning.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, it was great though.
I'm so glad that we're not... we're never cured.
That girl's gonna stay blind forever.
Unfortunate to that girl.
She's gonna... she's just gonna be blind forever.
No do over.
Oh!
That's so fun!
I'm really happy.
Our very first JRPG.
I don't know what series to start next week.
There's so many games I really... I really want to play God of War.
I really do want to try out God of War.
Because I never played God of War before.
But there's so many choices.
It's so hard to pick.
I can now play like any... it's like you know when you can play any game you want now.
It's just like, what do I... what do I play?
It's like when you have so many choices, you don't know what choice to make.
Type deal.
But I'll think about it.
I don't know if I start... start with like the very... or I could play...
The reason why I haven't played Elden Ring yet is because everybody is playing Elden Ring.
Like everyone is playing Elden Ring.
And like I feel like everyone is playing Elden Ring.
Everyone is getting like Elden Ring fatigue.
Like every corporate Vtuber, every indie Vtuber, every flesh tuber, everybody is playing Elden Ring.
So I want to wait a little bit when... when things cool down a little bit.
Because I feel like you've watched people play it... fucking kill the same boss a hundred million times in the last two weeks now.
So that's why I've been like, alright I'm going to wait until like you know less people...
It's like super over saturated.
Yeah, it's super over... saturated.
So that's why I haven't touched it yet.
But definitely will in the future.
I promise you guys.
I mean it was a charity goal.
So I'll definitely do it in the future.
There's so many things I have to do in the future.
But yeah, it was great.
I had a great time.
Oh my gosh, it's been five... I've been streaming five hours and it's so long.
How about FPS?
I want... well FPS...
I want to try... what is it called?
Is it Trip Pan?
Let's see... is it Trip Pan 2?
I want to try that.
Apparently that game is really good.
I may try that game.
Maybe next... next week.
That's the...
Yeah, maybe next week I'll try that one.
That's something I've been thinking about too.
Is it good?
Is it really good?
I might do that next week actually.
If it's... if you guys think it's like worth it.
It has a lot of reviews.
I was looking through it.
I know it's a little spooky so...
So I don't know.
The only thing I'm worried about is that it is a little spooky.
Anyway.
Alright, I know I'm gonna call it here guys.
Because I do have a lot of behind the scenes work to do.
I really wish I could have talked to you guys more.
But don't worry, things are gonna cool down soon.
I swear.
After Anime Expo, things will definitely cool down a lot more now.
So... and I'll be able to actually hang out with you guys.
And have more like actual Zatsudon with all of you guys.
Post game Zatsudons again.
And Super Chat readings.
But thank you everybody.
I hope you guys enjoyed my very first time finishing a JRPG!
We should all be proud.
We stuck out.
We fucking did it guys.
We stuck it to the end.
Because I know Sadland was a lot.
But I'm so happy for all you Dragoons who stuck out to the very end.
To the last play through of Sadland.
We should all be proud of ourselves.
We all accomplished something today.
Gladstone, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Do you think any of us Dragoons watch anyone else?
Sounds like someone's making excuses.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
No, it's not an excuse guys.
I hope you guys enjoy the new emotes everybody.
I'm slowly adding... I'm slowly commissioning more and more emotes now.
To fill up our slots.
So yeah.
Anyway guys, as always everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye everyone.
Bye.
JP, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
We were here till the end.
You were here.
Bye guys.
Bye.